i got hit in the hair with a shirt you
can't play with a shovel how hard are we
talking like
just like a little like yeah because
because like
a great weapon but if you hit it with
the concave side it's not that bad on
your skull
did we do a sound check oh yeah we did
okay wait were you not paying attention
oh no all right i was waiting for you to
get out of the [ __ ]
i refused to get out of the [ __ ] again
getting out of the shooter
you're right yeah i'm ready to go i
heard the word rolling up looking down
this camera oh okay
man this is more professional we are all
right all right should we count it in
should we give it a uh
i'll count it in i'll cancel all right
this is way more serious
all right we're rolling quite on set all
right and we're live
in five four three
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
your host for this week
for the first time in a while and with
me are the boys as usual
and we have a guest introduce yourself
hello podcast listeners and video
viewers
my name is ladybeard i'm thrilled to be
here today
on the trash tape
told us we
that's how this started for viewers at
home we had a pre-production meeting in
denny's
and the old lady generous way of warding
yeah
it's just a lunch yeah we we ate lunch
at denny's before we did this and uh the
old lady who works at denny's
made a point of coming up to us to tell
us that we were no she made a point of
coming up to you
we're regulars though yeah yeah we can't
go back there
and there's a guy who just knows the
exact time and like the exact day that
we come in
when we come early he's like oh you're a
bit earlier than usual yeah that's great
that's fantastic you're regulars that's
wonderful sorry um
are we allowed to am i like to say the
the general area of japan which the
studio is in
no no we're in japan we're in japan
in the same general area right now
i actually have a reputation of ruining
things for people because
one of my best friends lives in this
general area too yeah and so there was a
night when
i went uh to his house and um we played
this game
okay i'm scared now
we're playing this game when we went
walking out it's the middle of summer
time we're about two
three in the morning we went out to do
the convenience store and the things you
normally do
and we played this game of you know
there's only certain institutions that
are open at that time
right right so we made this game when we
would go into the institution you know
japan they have the little trade to put
your money in when you pay
yeah yeah we made this game out we go
and we you know do whatever buy our
stuff at the convenience store
and then we would flip over the tray and
see how they reacted
because a lot of people in japan people
working the service industry
can't handle that right
it blew minds you see i've ever said
they got the convenience store
it was it was a bit it was it was
probably a bit nasty because my friend
is this huge bodybuilder guy right
so i'm a pro wrestler so we're there and
the dude behind the convenience it's 3am
there's two foreigners there's no other
humans for miles around he's this tiny
little dude and i'm like
but what would you do sir if i did
this and i flipped the tray and just
waited he was looking
like you're maintaining icons freaked
out he freaked out
he will never talk to a foreigner ever
again anyway but then the game became
you would run into an institution you'd
flip the tray and run out
see what would happen basically just
ding dong dashing yeah well basically
now my friend can't go to sutaya anymore
well because because he's known as that
giant dude who flips trays over
the uh arnold schwarzenegger he's
running with his shirt
okay sorry first of all i think there's
only a lot of confusion
we just jumped right in here let's uh
yeah let's let's
dial it back a bit let's let's let's go
back a bit you want to introduce
yourself to audiences who don't know
what are you doing or what do you do
why are you wearing it because to
someone who doesn't because there's
someone who doesn't know who ladybird is
they're probably just thinking who is
this white guy in a dress random aussie
you just joined the trash chase
i don't know anything i i want to come
into this blind i wanted to hear
and meet you and experience everything
so i know absolutely nothing about you
i am connor's biggest fan as
[Music]
in the short time i've known him um let
me introduce myself
watch this i'll do it like we're uh like
we're on tv this is channel seven right
here ready
my name's ladybeard i'm a heavy metal
singer and pro wrestler
from australia currently based in japan
today i'm thrilled to be talking to my
friends the question that you've been
it's very creepy
this is crazy it's the quietest you've
been in a long time
that was like australian like news
documentary narration voice yes
it was wasn't it yeah so but i didn't go
up at the end of my sentence
the way i potentially should have like
every australian girl
here in
there's no need to talk about the
wonderful nation of australia from which
uh both
joseph and i hail we get we get we can
get to that though we can get together
so how does this come to be what is so
um
uh i am a heavy metal singer and a pro
wrestler
wait which one were you first dresser i
was first a cross dresser
oh really and became a cross-dressing
pro wrestler right and then became a
cross-dressing
wrestling heavy metal what what is what
is the journey
i feel like you're saying these steps
i'm trying to break these down
that's like that's like someone being
like i was uh a straight man
and then i went a straight man who
became an astrophysicist
and then i became a straight man who did
astrophysicists and does gardening
everything i feel like
are you not those things yes i thought
that's what this was yeah i feel like
there's a story that gets for us from
point a to point b but i'm just not
seeing it so
i okay i used to live in uh the city of
hong kong
and i was an actor and a voice actor and
a programmer
how did you get to hong kong no no no no
you're adding like five more different
points this
what made you leave australia let's
start there okay so okay um
i i i went through acting school in
australia okay
to be an actor okay but that's mainly
what acting school's for yes yes
mainly makes sense but i also am a
martial artist
okay and so what happened was i then i
moved from
adelaide that's where i'm from which as
joey will know is a small city
yes to melbourne right joey will know is
a big city
a bigger a bigger city this isn't a
child series
and so i was training in in hong kong
style
um like cinematic action with uh this
aussie dude who was on jackie chan's
stunt team right oh wow so i was on his
stunt team right
and um basically there was no work
factors in australia at the time
so i'm there and i'm auditioning and
things and i'm auditioning against like
aussie celebrities and things so there's
no way as a school leaver i'm gonna get
a bloody joy right
so this stunt dude i was training with
he was like you should go to hong kong
because worst case scenario you'll go
there you'll get a bit of work
because it's easier because you're a
foreigner so you've got less competition
then you can come back here and be more
employable
right go to auditions right and they'd
be like yeah you're good
but you need experience cash 22 how are
you going to get experience
that's right so it's like they tell me
somehow you have to get experience
we're not going to help you all right so
anyway so yeah i went to hong kong
playing just do a couple of movies and
then come home
i ended up staying six years
so i say that so casually there was much
more work to be had in hong kong then
there was at home right right
like you just stayed around a mates
just in case you just kept getting
working hard yeah well there was much
more to do there yeah there's much more
to do there
but so that's interesting so i went in
uh 2006.
um i had a brief stint when i moved to
the philippines because i got a job
offer down there to work at a movie
studio
but then i was there for about six
months and i went back to hong kong
right doing my stuff but then
then and this is mainly doing like
martial arts and martial arts acting
voice acting and stunt right of
everything yeah
yeah well throughout acting school
you'll learn to be an actor and you
learn voice acting
right and then i was a martial artist so
like stunts off the back of that right
right so then um
but then so then okay go two thousand
six six seven
eight i'm there end of 2008 along comes
that global financial crisis
and wipes out everything i had going on
yeah right i'm like all right well
nothing to go back to at home
now there's nothing here what am i going
to do right
and i made the logical choice of
realizing the way to solve all my
problems was to become a cross-dressing
pro wrestler and heavy metal singer
okay okay so how did you how did you
come to that realization
like this is
let's take it one step at a time right
like so have you always had
i assume you've always had a fascination
towards wrestling uh yeah so a
martial artist obviously yeah yeah and
also performer
and stunt man so really pro wrestling's
a small skipper yeah yeah yeah
i was always interested in wrestling
when i was younger but um here just due
to where i lived in adelaide and where
the wrestling gyms were they were miles
away so i never had the chance to
actually
do it did you watch like wwe yeah but
there wasn't
when i was at the age to watch all that
it wasn't on tv very readily in adelaide
it was on like 1 30 in the morning yeah
yeah
thursday yeah so it's like you know well
only the naughty kids
studying for like yeah catch the wwe
sometimes
yeah but i'm um you're of a different
generation than i
i think without giving up too many
things yeah the wrestlers you watched
are probably different from the ones i
want i mean
to be frank i didn't really watch a
whole lot of wrestling youtube
my wrestling knowledge of like back you
know when i was like in
teenage years yeah all of it comes from
all the wwe games that my
neighbor used to have okay so like you
know be like
back then when it was i think it was
still smackdown versus raw yeah right
like that kind of like level so
it's like you know it's like very big i
wouldn't call myself a wrestling fan but
that's around the time
when i was getting access to this 1 30
in the morning right
right but you had to have foxtel to be
able to watch the damn wrestling i
didn't have foxtel
yeah fox tellers like uh like a cable
like sky
okay that's what i like like sky yeah
basically yeah but in australia sky is
that
conservative news network so i don't say
sky because it's a very different thing
in australia is it
too many people use the same words for
their media outlets
so okay so then i want to know then if
that's the case okay so you're like
so okay so you're like into wrestling
and you're like okay it's just a
logical you know progress to go into
wrestling yeah so then so like how do
you
okay i've always wondered because i knew
i know a few people who like used to be
pro wrestlers or currently do progress
okay
how do you even start to get into an
industry like that well you go and you
go to wrestling school
so you go to a wrestling gym and you'll
do a try out to see whether or not they
will train you all right
and if they accept you then they accept
you and they start training you right
what do they look for what's like what's
like the audition
well you need to have um you know
physically you need to be able to handle
the physical stuff yeah
and then you know from a um i guess a
presentation a performance perspective
you need to have uh
some level of aptitude in that
absolutely championship
yeah you don't necessarily need to be
trained in anything already but if
you're super shy and you can't handle
being in front of an audience it's not
going to work out great
wrestling is generally speaking about
larger than life characters yeah yeah
yeah
and many dresses or men in dresses
how did you go from that to moving to
japan then so
okay so uh financial crisis
uh all the work's gone um but around
that time i started wrestling in hong
kong because there was a gym that was
accessible to me for the first time
started wrestling um started training a
month later i caught on fairly quickly
because the
techniques are not that different from
stunts right right a month later i had
my first
match and so we're getting ready for
yeah that's too fast yeah
anyone who's training care a month
is too fast i feel a month is too fast
for any training
let's go from your first body slam to
doing in front of people
right so so is when you say
first wrestling match is like a whole
coordinated this you do this i do this
kind of thing or is it literally just
you
like how does that work i have no idea
um well sorry in wrestling it's uh
okay so there's like a system right
right once you learn the system
then you can work so if i know what i'm
doing if you i'm trying to the system
and you're trained to the system
um okay sorry it's all right it's all
right connor
i don't know because you know with that
because i
you know i mean you know because it's an
act but you know it's not an act
right but i don't i don't know what i
mean that wrestling is fake connor
so this is conor mcgregor right mma it's
the real thing
mcgregor well on top of the morning to
you i thought this was the joe rogan
experience
this is not the joke connor what's going
on it's a podcast
i was lying too
i'm so confused right
your last name's not mcgregor what's
your what should i call you by your last
name ladybeat is literally
in every lady is in like and i see
and i say this in the nicest way
possible is one of the hardest people to
work with
oh [ __ ]
like i just said like i literally just
said this man is like
he's destroying the set within jesus
christ 10 minutes of recording
yeah they can't walk correctly
all right let's let's cut sorry
we're talking about wrestling how it
works then of course you were saying
about you know you had one month of
training before your first year
yeah so then so then we're there and
we're discussing before this match okay
so what do you want your character to be
your gimmick
and that's referred to a pro wrestling
and um i have
a long history in cross-dressing
yeah yeah so can we talk about that well
yeah we completely missed that i think
we forgot
yeah so how did that come today so when
i was 14
a friend of mine had a school uniform
birthday party and i thought
what's the school uniformed birthday
party have you never been to a party in
your life no but like what do you mean
that was like school you know
that was not special about it cut that
cut the lady be an aggression
that's fine i secretly love you it's
okay i just i just genuinely wanted to
know what a school uniform birthday
party
what is that a school uniform birthday
party
is a birthday party to which in when
you're in school
yeah yeah school uniforms isn't that
just like
a normal party isn't that just like an
after-school party yeah
yeah but you don't go after school it's
like on the weekend or whatever
what i want to know is why you want to
want to choose to wear a school uniform
to go to a party because
it's my friend's birthday and she can do
whatever she wants
to cry if she wants to you would cry too
if it happened to you
okay okay so you went to a school
uniform birthday party school uniform
birthday party and i saw my mates went
wearing what we would at school
so wearing the trousers and the blazer
and the shirt and everything yeah and i
was like
it'd be really funny if i wore my big
sister's school dress right
okay i did and it was a hit amongst the
14 year old
yeah that'd be hilarious it was
hilarious right it was it was yeah and
so
um then what happened is i started them
wearing that particular school dress
to various other non-school uniform
parties right and rock and roll shows
and things
and what happens is i noticed that this
is back in the 90s yes so it's a
different time from now
um as a man in address young man in a
dress i will walk into the room
and the energy of the room would lift
straight away so
you know how at the start of every party
there's like that two hours of faffing
around when everyone's not really loose
and everyone's going
yeah it's great i can see that yeah
that's kind of what i do on my youtube
channel yeah
exactly right i don't know it's freeing
you know you feel like when you're the
clown you can do anything you know what
i mean
what you do what you're progressing i've
done a lot of crossdressing on my
youtube channel i guess yeah
oh good it's quite fun i mean i feel
like when you're when you know you're
the butt of the joke
it's soaking like i don't know it's so
like freeing it's so control like
because you feel like you're the one in
control
yeah that's that's not how i felt it for
me it was not butt of the joke but i
appreciate what you're saying though
i appreciate what you're saying um but
definitely when you're the object of
attention
yeah yeah yeah what i found is it's
become a different conversation recently
because
the whole transgender movement is yeah
so now it's a different conversation
from what it was when i started
right but for me it was a case of i was
more successful at
life when wearing a dress than when
wearing pants
right which is an interesting thing
really because a lot of transgender
people would have the opposite
experience they were trying to
say they wanted to express themselves by
wearing dresses
and then they felt they couldn't but for
me i was dressed like a dude and it was
like
and then i put on a dress everyone's
like whoa so i think there's a lot of
insecurity out there with guys whether
like if you say it's a joke it's
hilarious
but if you're like no i like this so
like i don't know how to feel about that
there is some of that which i mean i
mean just talking to you now you
definitely bring
the energy wherever you go so i think
yeah
yeah i i feel it's like the energy was
there before the skirt came on you know
but sort of um like on what you just
said yeah yeah but i turn up in this and
i'm all energetic everybody goes well
that makes sense
right yeah why not just turn up your
pants an old lady in denny's tells me to
shut up
you know what i'm saying right am i
wrong am i wrong
i mean i am curious i think i think the
outfit wouldn't have mattered
i think she was going to tell you to
shut the [ __ ] up i am curious in the
country of noise complaints how many
noise
just how many noise complaints have you
got oh dear me dmv
it's a nonstop stream of noise
complaints
walking down the street
constantly how do you not like i don't
know because i guess you know you had
that like voice acting experience right
so i guess like the whole like you know
using your voice and being loud and all
that it's just like kind of
ingrained into you almost i just saved
that [ __ ] what do you mean oh really
that's optional um uh
yeah but it's i think it's more just a
personality personality trait
yeah and on top of that i'm a younger
sibling so i had to do something to get
some damn attention
look at me frankly so
where am i in this story yes so okay so
i was a
casual crossdresser and then when i
moved to hong kong i started
cross-dressing in the same capacity so
just going out to rock and roll shows
and things in a dress
right because hong kong's such a
conservative society yep that
yo if i lifted the energy in australia
in hong kong i really really like it
yeah
yeah i would walk in it was just ah
people just lost their minds
you're like the funniest person i've
ever seen in my life they went
bonkers for it so i'm like damn so
so there we are and we're um you know
figuring out
characters for the first wrestling match
every other wrestler
every other wrestler in hong kong their
gimmick was i am a wrestler
right right right so i'm like like
nothing interesting
exactly yeah he's a wrestler yeah is
that all yes
okay so i'm like um what are you good at
i wrestle
what is your name wrestler the wrestler
um so i'm like i'm gonna uh wear a dress
and i'm gonna be called ladybeard
right so all the other wrestlers were
like uh
okay and they were weird about it right
right
first match i go in there overnight most
popular restaurant in hong kong damn
because i was the only one who had a
character try because everyone else was
a wrestler the same as the other 20
wrestlers they just seen come out for
him
so what i want to know how is like i
assume this is like the amateur
wrestling scene how did they
how did they introduce new wrestlers um
what's the process for that
well uh okay so like i say you go
through
you you do a try out and then agree to
train you you start training
okay and then when you get when you're
kind of released publicly as in when
you're debuted
yeah uh they'll find a way to debut you
so normally you do it with something
public like a wrestling show
or like a video segment or something
like that yeah and um they'll just
like whoever you are in the ring and
however you're going to fit into the
company and the stories and so forth
they'll just find a way that works to
introduce your character so let's say
for instance right now
let's say we've been training gantt and
uh for the past year and gantt's now a
skilled young pro wrestler as you can
see
so um okay so what's what's make a
gimmick for you real quick
you are the um the you're the the thai
elephant god
sorry okay here's the thai elephant god
and we've decided and currently
uh joey who is the um uh slightly
colorful head
luchador
okay he's in a feud with connor
um uh the welsh despair sorry okay
you two are shooting just being watched
you two are feuding why does the welsh
despair sound so cool
i was trying to make it worth the start
with w but i couldn't think of it i'm
the multi-colored luchador
like what the [ __ ] what would you like
to be
anything else would be fine really other
than what's a gimmick
i have interesting colored hair
cool thanks the standard of hong kong
yeah
that didn't even have interesting color
that sounded rude okay so okay so okay
so that's my wristband
anyway okay so let's say you guys are
feuding um we'll find some kind of angle
in which during your story uh
for some reason the thai elephant god
is paying huge homage to the uh
multi-colored uh
luchador yeah right and to that end when
you guys are in a match
joey will hit his finisher and he'll
like cover connor it'll be one
two and then the lights will go off and
they'll come on
and riding down the ramp on an elephant
is the thai elephant god
right so let everybody know that the
match is not gonna end like this
right right or just any damn way you
want to do it
this is one of the beautiful things
about wrestling there's a lot of
potential for creativity and so forth so
so did you get to like say
for instance like the entry right like i
think from what i've heard like each
wrestler
they do they get to choose what song
they enter with
uh yeah it depends on your company
really right right right but like you
but like basically the wrestler like
every other time like they get to choose
how they want to enter i always
i personally got to but of course you're
limited by you know what you're
capable of doing well copyright i
imagine yeah
uh well yeah it can't be a problem but
it's kind of like if you're small time
you're often too
too small right yeah big time they've
got the rights cleared so right so
what's what's like say like for you for
example like what's like your
pinnacle of entries that you remember
because i've seen some because recently
aki has been getting into
wwe oh okay which is like slightly
worrying as well
because i'm like is she gonna be a wwe
girlfriend i don't know about that
but she's but she was watching we were
watching uh like i think it was like the
top 10 like wwe
like most memorable wwe entries and the
one that [ __ ] killed me was one that
john cena did
where he literally somehow got
a hundred john cena look-alikes to come
out in this like
like just this [ __ ] row of people and
they would part ways and
create this like aisle it's the most
accurate thing
the part ways and create this aisle and
then the moment the fireworks went off
they all turned to each other and start
doing this
and then the real john cena comes and he
just runs through them
so fantastic did you ever get to do
something like that uh uh let me tell
you something joey
the budget that's been dedicated is not
the same as one of the dedicated john
cena okay well then what
what would you say is like yeah this is
like the peak of my entry
of like a ring of like a ring entrance i
don't know i don't think i've done
anything particularly special as a ring
entrance you don't really like off the
top of my head
no i don't think i've ever done it you
just you just kind of show up
get announced you know come out get
big light on you yeah go around
high-fiving the audience yeah
into ring but you got to remember when i
come out i've got pigtails in a pink and
white bikini so
just that is somewhat a statement sure i
don't need to do this joey
everyone's looking already i want them
to see me
all right so you did only terrible only
terrible wwe jokes
so okay so we established the
cross-dressing thing we've established
the pro wrestling thing yeah yeah
metal singing how did that come from so
um so when i moved to hong kong i
started learning cantonese because
that's the language i speak there and so
um one of the strategies i had for
learning languages was i would get
music in that language which i'm sure
you guys have probably gone through here
with japanese yeah
not connor from the look on his face but
you get music that you like in the
language yeah
so i started listening to uh cantonese
pop songs
most of the music is pop there's very
little anything else in hong kong right
so i'll miss these pop songs um and my
favorite numbers are metalhead
from way back actually my favorite songs
full stop were always like metal covers
of pop songs
right right right so like you know metal
covers of like last friday night and
yeah [ __ ] your face and things like that
yeah because they're hilarious right
because you're so used to hearing
lady gaga with you know carrying my
pocket
and then you hear you gotta rub my bow
oh
that's so funny right i think it's
fantastic because it takes what you're
used to and it subverts it
yeah yeah that's a thing of beauty so
when i started listening to these
candies pop songs i was like these are
really catchy songs
who's done the medal covers turns out no
one had right and i was like well
someone should do that
free real estate it's three years later
um i uh it was after the financial
crisis everything had been wiped out
what am i gonna do i was uh going
through like one of those exercises
where you figure out your career and
what you're gonna do
it's like what are you passionate about
and i'm like a heavy metal and
destroying things
so i'm like okay i wanna be a metal
singer and i was like okay
specifically i want to sing metal covers
of cantonese pop songs because i think
they'll sound awesome
no one else has done it i'm going to
goddamn do it yeah wow so i did and then
what i said was okay so i've already got
this
fan base organized with the wrestling
i'm going to do this metal project
as ladybeard and i'm going to bring that
fan base over and then i'm going to try
and do this amazing interesting thing of
working
the pro wrestling world and the heavy
metal world together so
the storylines are interlocked and they
flow back and forth between
15 years too early to tick-tock yeah i
feel like those
heavy metal covers would blow up on
ticks yeah exactly
hearing you talk about the financial
crisis is like this devastating thing is
so bizarre because i was just so young
i'm pretty [ __ ] myself from watching
finding nemo the thought of
having an impact yeah i mean what it was
2008 right yeah i was 14.
i was i was in university so i was
probably 12 or something i'm 24.
holy smoker rooney yeah i mean like you
know i
was like i think i was 11 then yeah
because i had heard like from my parents
being like you know like damn the wall
got [ __ ] over there that's a big thing
that's going to happen and i'm just like
i'm just trying to get through my degree
right now
i'm still probably eating coco pops and
you know picking my nose
but we've got to realize the same kind
of thing has happened now with coconut
19.
all four of us are very lucky that we
can still sit here employ absolutely
exactly
a lot of people are now in that position
that i was in then
and they're going god what am i going to
do yeah so the next generation of
ladybeard is going to come out
a couple of years from now they'll be
like a little 2.0 of course with a pink
mess
yeah so that's so yeah that's how it
came to
when did you move to japan then so then
um so i started doing my metal covers of
candidates pop songs and i started doing
that in hong kong
very good um did a couple of tours to
some nearby places and i
said one of the things that kind of gave
me the confidence to do it in the first
place
because it's sort of when you go full
time as the crossdresser
you can't ever really go back can you
it's kind of it works
or you're screwed right right right so
one of the things that kind of gave me
the confidence to do it was well if i
can't really get anything going on in
hong kong
i know i can always move to japan
because i'm sure they'll love something
like that oh yeah
yeah yeah so i did a tour to japan after
i got myself organized in hong kong
um did japanese songs so i couldn't
speak japanese yet just learnt the songs
phonetically
oh wow put together a show yeah came
over here with you know the handful of
contacts i had like
three japanese people i knew right so i
put together a show
but it popped because i was doing like
covers of metal covers of like um
what's that girl who sings first love
hikaru what's that no that's that's a
wrestler
yeah thank you very much yeah yeah doing
like metal covers of that and so forth
so the audience much they didn't know
who i was right the audience who was at
any of these shows
would see this show they all knew the
songs because they're famous songs yeah
they'd they'd be the metal cover of
course they're like
this is hilarious yeah so that too it
went incredibly well right
so i'm like okay well clearly i found
the chosen land
promised land that's written in the
ancient texts
the ancients promised the promised land
of milk and honey
so i uh yeah so i went back to hong kong
and i'm like all right clearly the
mission now needs to be moved to japan
and
japan and i did and here we are oh wow
man do you know what it feels like you
know when you like you put your
headphones in your pocket and it gets a
little tangled and you have to like
untangle it
that's literally what we did with your
story right now
it all finally fits together it all
makes sense now it's all finally one
straight line
that i can copy that i can understand
yeah so i came over at the end of 2013
right and then at the start of 2014 my
images
went uh viral on the twitter
and um then um in 2015 i was put in this
pop group with these uh
two young singers and uh we did a song
called nippon manju and that blew up on
the youtubes
and um now we're riding high
so okay then like because i would say
like for people who
don't know ladybird for instance i'd say
like i i would say though like
if there's one thing about you that
you've done in your career that's
probably
i would say it's probably the most
well-known would probably be ladybaby of
course yeah right so how did that come
to be
so i was uh it was me and my former
manager
um we're in japan we're only doing our
stuff in japan and so forth
and uh so i was on the cover of
metropolis magazine do you know that
magazine i've definitely heard of that
yeah it's it's a free magazine how can
you guys be foreign in japan not
metropolis
leave my house fair enough
there's a free english magazine like a
street magazine
in tokyo i think in all japan called
metropolis is there i
don't know i've never seen it i've never
seen it i'm definitely afraid of eye
contact with strangers holding things
i'm like don't don't no no
i thought you welshman loved a good
fight
jimmy's a metropolis magazine
i never read a good fight i think i'd be
deported
very quickly
so there's this magazine yeah well it's
a very popular
magazine amongst every foreigner in
japan except
one two three yeah mainly did you know
about this
yeah right actually did you know about
these teachers
yes there are five foreigners here who
didn't know about it
my friends who work at metropolis
magazine i sincerely apologize for this
negative price
that you are currently receiving on the
trash i'm just saying podcast clearly
the marketing strategy needs to be
written
yeah dude that magazine is everywhere oh
it's clearly
not everywhere like like convenience
store
no i don't care if you've gone to tower
records or whatnot they've got that
stack of free magazines i don't think
i've been into a tower records in about
a year
you look at the free stack of magazines
i just see potential toilets when you
get to the airport are you walking
from your plane to immigration there's
all those magazines and stuff
i have yeah you're just checking your
phone right i guess
young people bloody generation
millennials okay so you're on the oh
yeah you're on the
the ceo of a halloween costume company
is uh getting off a plane he's walking
through the airport
and he sees metropolis magazine with me
on it it's me and my pinker white bikini
flexing
and he said what the hell is that
[Music]
he's actually chinese so i probably said
that's probably
just like my nigga's own business
bluetooth headphone in his ear and he's
just like
the [ __ ] is that so he takes magazine
yeah and he takes it back to his office
and he's like look at this
and his staff are like yeah that's this
ladybeard guy he's foreign a dude
and he said bring him in i want to work
with him bring him in
wow so we get a contact from this
company and we go in
and he's like i want to work with you
i'm like all right i thought he
was a halloween costume company right so
i thought he's going to make like a
line of my bikinis right right yeah he's
like i want to work with you but i don't
know how
so we'll be in touch okay like okay
yeah yeah we go back to what we were
doing and a month later he calls us in
again yeah and he's like i'm going to
put you in a pop group with a pair of uh
idols
wow wait wait how did that happen that's
another jump
yeah how did he come up with that i
wasn't there for that okay you know
okay he did that in the privacy your
life just sounds like a roulette wheel
what is going on
well that's what you get for waking up
in face
yeah it's it's just like here's a bunch
of money's like oh i don't even remember
bending on black
i was like um uh anyways okay so
so this guy somehow manages to get you
in this idle group
yeah so he spoke to some people he knew
and
he's i'm gonna put you in a group and
then we did that first song and it blew
up and that was lady baby uh
wow so he somehow knew babymetal
wait what baby were they even
established yeah they were
they were very popular at the time
recently after give me chocolate oh
okay yeah yeah so they were very hot and
they were getting spoken about a lot in
japan
but it's like i remember the meeting
he goes yeah because he's a heavy metal
singer and they're idols
yeah yeah so your baby metal are very
popular at the moment aren't they yeah
this will be just like babymetal but
with ladybeard
ladybeard babymetal
baby that was the meaning i'm like right
really cool i guess this one happened
this was the ceo of a halloween costume
costume and they just decided to get
into the same because
making skills right there he's a smart
man he uh
he's from china he came over to japan
like with no money
like 30 years ago or something and he
made his living
like he'd go outside tokyo domes during
the bubble outside tokyo dome
he would like sell like light sticks or
something
events yeah and he somehow made his
business happen that is literally
how like every entrepreneur in the 70s
started like that isn't that like every
entrepreneur's story from there
it's just like i had no money when
coming to this country in the streets i
sold it i sold paper clips and now i own
a multi-million dollar corporation
man my dad was rich gave me a small loan
of a million dollars
this episode is sponsored by harry's you
know why you shouldn't have to choose
between gentlemen
what a great shave and a fair price i'm
always trying to choose between the two
and frankly i'm quite sick of it that's
where you're wrong joey because
with harry's you won't have to oh my god
and as you guys know last time when we
promoted harry's they gave us the box to
promote and actually took it home and
used it
and gentlemen was it good it's [ __ ]
good really it's good i mean you are the
hairiest member of trash
i know i know i'm always shaving here
and it was so clean much better the ones
that i get from the store i know that
sounds like an ad like like i'm being
told say that but yeah
it's legit that that's 100 that's good
harry's delivers a close
comfortable shave at a fair price still
as low as
two dollars per refill that's actually
really [ __ ] good and for a limited
time
harry's is offering their starter set
plus a free travel size
body wash at harrys.com trash taste as
you guys know from our previous harry
sponsorship they have their own german
factory that makes blades to a precision
they've been doing it for over 100 years
to give you that clean
shave that's why you [ __ ] love it
right that's why i love it and there's
no gimmicks or unnecessary features it's
just a damn
good razor combined with a weighted
handle
an ergonomic texture grip and flex hinge
i don't even know what most of these
words mean but all i know is that it was
a damn good it sounds clean as [ __ ]
plus there is a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed harry stands
behind the quality of their blades so
much that they have a 100
money-back guarantee on harry.com and
the prices are pretty damn fair
i've already talked about the price
that's pretty damn good in my opinion
so what are you waiting for for a
limited time harry's has made their
exclusive offer
even better for listeners of this show
new customers can get the special offer
and the harry starter set and body wash
at
harrys.com trash taste and
if you go there you'll get a 5 blade
razor weighted truman handle
foaming shave gel a travel blade cover
and a travel size
body wash and it's pretty damn good by
the way there's never been a better time
to go to harry so go to harry's dot com
trash taste to redeem your offer today
thank you to harris for sponsoring the
episode back to the show all right
gentlemen i'm gonna bring us back in
from the commercial break
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it as if as
if um
we're in south africa i'm gonna do it in
an afrikaans accent well
why south africa you'll be yourself out
i'll tell you
i'll tell you why in a second but let me
just bring us back in for this coming
okay okay ready
okay i'm gonna do it like it's my south
africans great right
these actually you ready here we go
welcome back to the trish taste podcast
on the voice of africa radio network
i'm your host ladybeard here today with
more guests connor
gaunt and joey gentlemen how are you
that's actually really good
for south africa at the moment you sound
you sound like my math teacher back in
high school was he south africa he was
very south africa okay go on yeah
if you're like no he's not if any
africana were offended by my accent i
was not trying to appropriate your
culture
i can't i have so my shower curtain
you know what this is like this is the
conversation equivalent of like changing
we have been tabs completely drunk for
episodes so we're easier to follow than
this
what is going on okay
is a very badly produced map of the
world
okay so when i was buying shower
curtains from whichever shower coat
dispensary i was
buy from right probably wasn't amazon
because i'm too old so
i was uh i bought the cheapest one and
it was a very poorly produced map of the
world
okay and like it's like the borders are
in the wrong places
the colours of the countries bleed over
the borders things are spelt wrong
and um one of the things it does is on a
country
it does not highlight the biggest city
or the capital city
it highlights some other cities just
some random city cities are left out
right so fritz is in australia i think
in australia they managed to get
canberra so that was
that was right at least they got the
capital yeah in japan it's sendai
and no other city right um and then uh
and then so then so then all right so so
how does that lead to your afrikaans
accent
this this connection i wanna see when
i'm
sitting on the toilet and i won't go
into detail about what's going on at the
time oh we can imagine you can imagine
yes
um my eye line is such that i look
directly
at that bottom part of africa on this
map so it's like south africa namibia
botswana
right right right and on the south
africa because it's a dodgy map
there's no cape town there's no
johannesburg right but there is
um bloom florentine
okay which is just some random town
blam flat it's firstly it's fun to say
say it with me you try what isn't it
blue and florentine bloomflam team that
was excellent
can you say that the welsh accent
you know what that sounds like that
sounds like that sounds like something
the swedish chef would say in the
muppets
this is a real place yeah it's a real
place for [ __ ] privileged people
laughing in africa
it's the capital of a part of south
africa called uh free state
okay this is the capital city slash
capital
of free state and that's everyone who's
watching this from bloomfield and it's
like why it's so
funny and bloom florentine is um
what i look at when i'm sitting on the
tv
[ __ ] okay okay and so for that reason i
did some research on bloomfluenty okay
and now my current my boom is south
africa
so so that's why you did the afrikaans
accent that's why i did the ephrata
collins accent
and you can call me i don't know an
africana surname what's a common
africana surname
you're asking as if i know dirt and dirt
and fault you can call me ladybird dirt
and fault
from here on in joey take it away i
don't i don't think i can take it away
we were on the we're on the way let's
let's let's lady baby yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's about to
bring us back
you guys you guys from now on can never
give a [ __ ] for the amount of tangents
we go on because that was easily the
biggest tangent we've ever been on i was
about to say we're quite famous for
going on tangents
and i swear there's like tangents within
tangents within tan just like when you
tell a singer
that was like that was like moving on to
a different shape tangent has ever been
started as beautifully as my shower
that's the greatest start to attention
okay okay where you started okay sorry
ladybug okay so a halloween costume ceo
put me in a pop group
okay later when you were in lady baby
and how would that go well
uh i was in lady baby so my first ever
song nippon manju blew up on the
internets
and it got very very popular and so now
we were the hottest group
and so when this was formed you had you
didn't have any say in who the two idols
were literally we're putting with two
people before i was told you're doing
this group yeah
that's right um so that happened uh i
was in lady baby for like a year and a
half or something
so i did like four singles with them
and then some other kind of b-side touch
songs as well um
due to a series of events i won't go
into uh i was
unceremonious relieved of my position
right yeah um and now they don't exist
anymore was it because you're uh at the
danny
time you know what yeah it turns out
when you choose a heavy metal singer you
want him to be as quiet
so then yeah so then you did the lady
baby stuff and then you kind of did a
whole
bunch did a bunch of other stuff uh my
time in that group
ended um they went on without me but now
they're done anyway yeah yeah that whole
thing has come to an end
um i went and uh i did some other stuff
uh but
now yeah you have a new group finally
got a new group right so everyone loved
ladybaby when i was there right so me
and the two cute little japanese girls
everyone loved it i'm like let's do that
again
for a series of reasons we couldn't for
five years
right basically sum it up japanese
showbiz politics right
basically we did some other stuff i was
have been happy with the other stuff
i've done
um but now we're in a position where we
can do it again
so i'm like sweet as let's do it again
so basically what we've done
is we've constructed as many of the
parts that came together to make nippon
manju as we could
we've reconstructed those right and
we're doing the same thing again
and it's i'm very excited because for
five years i've been
every day been told why'd you leave
ladybug i wanted you to keep doing it
every day for five years yeah so finally
i can do this formation again because
clearly it's it's what i want to do it's
what the whole world wants to see
so brace yourselves ladies and gentlemen
ladybeard2021 coming at you with brand
new group
i'm allowed to release brand new group's
name correct
ladies and gentlemen baby beard coming
at you baby
baby beard that makes
more sense than lady baby it does it
does like
like as a name right thought
i thought
let's ignore the one person in the room
who speaks english his idea of a good
english name
so baby beard is unlike donkey kong i'm
so excited
uh have you done stuff with them yet
i don't know if i said a good thing or a
bad thing
no we've done nothing
i'll have you know we have enough [ __ ]
accidentally it's funny
you ask that yeah because this whole
thing was ready to get up and get
running at the beginning of 2020.
we all know what happened today we all
know what happened to that yeah
so now we're in this um unique
position where we have a new group to
release
and we're not really capable of doing
all the things you normally do to
release a group
right you're kind of stuck
so what you need to do is you need to
head down
to the baby beard tick tock there you're
gonna see
all the latest from baby beard coming at
you
full of updates and all the things we're
gonna be doing as soon as we're allowed
to do normal things like be on a stage
i love how like these are the first
guest that we've had that's just like
[ __ ] the end of the show i'm promoting
my [ __ ] now
hi hi you're a true showman hey
hey hey
go to social media
[Laughter]
the instant ham do we have another one
that i'm forgetting about
we'll put all the links in the
description in the description
smash the like button that's what the
young people say nowadays but they don't
say it in the middle of the episode
at the end i think we're ending
this
every five minutes we're walking them
back every toilet break welcome back
anyway i have a new group called baby
beard me the two adorable japanese girls
it's gonna be fantastic
if you loved nippon manju you will love
this go watch it please oh
no i'm just i'm just glad you're the
victim today you're
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] so happens when
you bring a pro wrestler
joey's going to get body slammed through
this in a second right it's a great
table actually i'm just glad you're
sticking with something familiar for
once not going to like [ __ ]
astrophysics or something yeah yeah
right
you like me i don't know much about it
so i'm i'm curious when you made your
previous trip you said that you didn't
have a say in it did you get much say
when you're making this one like who you
wanted to bring on to it or was it
literally just
find me two cute japanese girls we held
auditions oh okay oh okay we held
auditions
and you got to choose and yeah so i was
on the audition panel tell you what
auditioning is a totally different thing
as in
being on the choosing side of the
audition because for my whole life i've
been on the
doing the auditions right yeah it's the
first time i've been on the you know
watching the audition side
it's a different game yeah but instantly
it's um it's very interesting because it
kind of
takes away any it means that all the
times you've been rejected in auditions
it no longer feels personal
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah push the panel
because you can see girls came in and
they were wonderful like they were
really good i was like i think you're
fantastic
but you're just not what we need right
now for
couple of them really good but just like
a bit too tall
things like this right so but it's kind
of upsetting because you're like i want
to give you a job but i just can't
yeah right right so what were you
looking for what was the criteria
well you had not too tall that's it
not too tall that's it
really oh no no what's gonna say there's
plenty of grandmas here so were you like
looking for like a certain like vocal
style
because i assume it's like they had to
be able to sing they had to be able to
dance
they had to be small enough they had to
be cute enough
um they had to be willing to normal idol
yeah
yeah but they had to be willing to go
all over the world
because you know when there's no
freaking bloody
death flu apocalypse we're playing it'd
be going all over the world
worse than it is
[Laughter]
that's what you should call baby maybe i
should yeah that's our second single
death flu apocalypse that's actually a
really good idea shiori make a note
please
death flew apocalypse um i can't
remember what we were saying
the criteria um
but i didn't it's uh yes you had to be
willing to go overseas
and uh they were the main criteria and
then it's also
standing with me and the other two does
that
the people balance it out a lot of us
like you're really good
we really like you but you don't
fit together with me and any of the
other girls you know
the hard thing i had to get two of them
right right one is relatively easy
two is hard right so you need two people
who can
match this up anyway we did uh we ended
up with two fantastic girls one called
kotomi
and one called suzu and foreigners
always think suzy's name is either susan
or souza
it's neither of those two think suzuki
without the key
scissor no you should just you should
just commit to the susan bit susan that
should be like her nickname really
yeah she's not a librarian is that
is every susan a librarian maybe they
are
i don't know a single susan single susan
i know single susan you're a single
sister
suddenly a single susan cannot be
established
in this or the susan's in the comments
section raise your hand right now
i'm a susan uh i am a big fan of susan's
everywhere
susans are wonderful people which
friends watch
what you think i love you i'm not trying
to offend you the point i'm trying to
make is
suzu is not named susan
that's the yeah but you made it sounded
like as if like i love everyone named
susan but these other names
yikes it's like oh
i'm knackered you're naked
so like okay so i guess like what did
you do
begin asking questions yeah right
because it's like [ __ ] is so crazy
[Music]
can i say the name of first single ah
please go to internets check out
bye baby man save people remaining pop
banjo it's amazing people
it's piece of musical madness it'll make
your
earbuds tingle with wonder you have
never heard
something as amazing of this adorable
japanese cute little idol voices
one noisy crossdresser screaming what
more could you want
in a musical product joey take us to a
commercial
our audio reader looks insane right now
you just destroyed why why are we
reading the ads yeah right
like the uh like the south african
survival kit
you ready but when i find myself lost
in it's always important to make sure
that i've got a survival kit with me
that way if i find myself without food
water or shelter there'll be something
i'll be able to do and you make it sound
like that town is like
a fever dream like yeah what have i
stumbled into today i
i've had i've had fever dreams that are
less weird than this i hope i hope there
are no south african ladies named susan
who happens to listen to this
if you're a south african named susan
leave a message in the comment box below
okay i'm curious so you you know you
obviously uh you said that you're gonna
be
touring worldwide yeah where is the
majority of your your audience japan
japanese so uh well obviously japan but
you know this is the group
um yeah we have the uh the death flu
apocalypse at the moment it's a little
bit hard to
establish physically where the audience
is gonna be my
personally um i have uh big fan bases
all over the world which is great
so we do the conventions like you
characters do yeah characters
do you not consider yourself a character
i mean the first time i met you was uh
oh god yeah that was yeah god how many
years ago was that that was 26
years ago 16 yeah 2016 five years five
years ago and like i had known about you
but then when i actually saw you in
person i was like oh [ __ ]
oh thank you that's that guy in the
dress yeah i feel like you know i don't
know if there's ruby i feel like a lot
of people know of you but they're not
like quite sure
you know because you're nick it's when
you you know your reputation proceeds
you see my face like great another white
guy
right you you know you see you it's like
it's kind of hard not to be like i think
i've seen this
watch my videos tons of them they'll be
like they'll catch me like do i know you
have you ever had anyone come up to you
and being like have you have you like
dead ass ever had anyone come up to you
being like
have i seen you before all the time
really it's much more like oh
ladybeard that's much better
people are like they're not sure if
you're ladybeard
uh yes yes really
yes but what because you're so like how
does that happen
what's interesting about being a
long-haired bearded white man in japan
is there's quite a lot of long-haired
beard right there in japan
really and i have been confused with
people such as
zack wilder
[Laughter]
who who
[Music]
i was standing at a bus stop in shibuya
i'm standing there waiting in my bus
stop
and this lady actually she was another
white lady all right i should say
another one because it's the first one
of the story apart from
south africa susan um she was a white
lady she comes up because she looks at
the bus stop she reads the times and she
sort of looks at me
reads the times he looks at the phone
there she goes
you look like jesus
you look like jesus i'm like ah thank
you she goes
can you do this i want to take a photo
and send it to my kids
what i'm like okay
[Laughter]
why her kids yeah
[Music]
i'm an atheist but i know you guys love
jesus wait
boy i think as far as people to look
like jesus is pretty good
i mean i've gotten that before as well
you got jesus when i had long hair
yeah japanese jesus yeah i feel like
anyone with like long hair and a slight
beard
i'm sure they've gotten back out you'll
be thai jesus no
it's literally it's literally literally
long hair
beard and you're tall right that's
that's the three steps to be jesus
yeah the three steps to me three steps
to be jesus
long hair beard and you're tall where's
the wiki how art's
have you ever had like crazy requests
like that from fans on the street
like to be like can you do this weird
thing i've never i've never asked to
t-pose before no i've never asked that
t-pose either i probably will do now
yeah it's good
yeah i'm like t t is there any uh
is there anything like i guess okay
because like i fell flat
no i was just trying to like formulate
my question there's so many things going
on
make sense of this chaos right now
sensory overload
[Laughter]
okay so because like i would say like i
think anyone can agree
right looking at your entire history you
have done
a lot of fun things you've done a lot of
different things is there like
anything that's that is a total
understatement but like is there
anything that you would personally like
to like
kind of add on to that is that like
another completely separate thing where
you're like
maybe down the road i'd like to do
something like that i've injured myself
now
i want to do a freaking baby beard as in
my time with ladybaby
was brought to a halt so prematurely and
so abruptly
and i'm not going to go into details but
look i was not really treated very
nicely in the process
right and that was so unfinished
that i feel a sense of um incompletion
if we don't go back and we don't finish
that cycle off now
yeah yeah um so that's kind of what i
want to do be there then beyond that
there's many other things that i want to
do
but um that'll like completely separate
yeah from what you want to do yeah
but i don't want to bring them up now oh
yeah i mean i guess you've got it
you've got to hide it right and kind of
reveal it oh look yeah or you just don't
want to share it well i mean if you say
it now
pressure from to do it oh yeah no it's
not that look
let's just stick with one thing we're
talking about at one time
so far we can't successful do we get the
rest of the podcast yeah
we've been unsuccessful because you go
on 17 million tangents
that was one accent that turned into a
different accent halfway through
i look i just want to do a baby a beard
that's
the thing i feel i can do it right now
without my life when we finish that i do
another thing
right now that's the thing a mamma mia
where did we go from here i like did we
get here
i'm like genuinely like i've never been
dumbfounded in my life can i ask a
question sure please
sure start yes your individual youtube
channel yes
how do you pronounce the name of that
gigguk did you pronounce the gig uk
like everyone else i said guy [ __ ]
that's the third alternative and then
and then
i thought potentially gg uk i thought
maybe you're just a huge girls
generation fan
gg uk let's see girls generation we'll
get caught
up oh really
claim yeah because you're just because
you're too good
archipelago you can't do an archipelago
no no no get out of here
you can get a copyright claim any song
no
get out of here ladybit discovers the
youtube algorithm
you've been spoiled by tick tock yeah
yeah so the youtube algorithm has gotten
so good now that they can detect
covers of songs people are just singing
what if you're trying to sing the song
be a really bad singer
no we're going to no heard i've heard
people like i've i've actually heard
stories of people
humming songs in their youtube videos
and getting copyright claims for it get
out of here what if you make an original
song
and purely by chance you accidentally
picked the same hope you get [ __ ] up
that's called
a lawsuit
no seriously you'll lose that yeah yeah
yeah you'll lose that
welcome to the youtube messages
it's it's today this is the first time
on the podcast where i've seen you
just be dumbfounded for words it's so
bizarre
i live in a universe where i like
pretend like music doesn't exist outside
of copyright free music
right um is there any questions you'd
like to
ask because i feel like we've asked like
literally every question we can ask you
it's been good i feel a bit selfish for
not talking about you people no no
no you're the guest our viewers know as
they're pretty [ __ ] sick of us
yeah yeah i was really enthusiastic to
hear about guy get slashed gg uk
so and now that that's done i wanted to
sing girls generation with everybody but
you can't
i'm curious have you ever had a normal
job
quite normal i'm just wondering because
i'm sitting here thinking right you know
if i went into like
you know i go into like h m yeah or just
there like i i kind of imagined i was
your t-shirt
i kind of i kind of sleep i can't
imagine you were like a big w
or anything like that you know like i
can't imagine you're like a regular
store
um i one of the reasons i've worked so
hard on this career
is exactly because i don't know don't
exactly fit it elsewhere
have you ever had a normal job yes i
don't know i guess my first jobs
were your first job i worked in retail
when i was like 18 or whatever what did
you do uh you know store in australia
girls clothing store called supra
yeah yeah yeah i worked at supreme you
worked at a super race
that's the first boy they ever hired
yeah how did that go
oh and now
um i'm very bad at normal jobs this is
why i've got
such a um i cannot imagine you working a
retail
at all i wasn't very good at it so i
worked retail and then i didn't enjoy it
much and so i stopped that and then i
became a dish pig in a restaurant right
so i was a dish pig in like the nicest
restaurant in adelaide oh wow yeah yeah
so that was one way that's a great in
some respects
the finest establishment welcome to
south australia
we have one mcdonald's yes i was a dish
pick of this restaurant was actually
actually quite a good job there are a
few things about it that made it hard
i was bad at the plates as in i was good
at doing the pans
right the frying pans of that i liked
that i was good at it
i was very slow at the plates and the
knives and forks so that ruined it for
me
because it's like more like fragile i
was just bad at it well with the pans
you've got
you're there with your sink pan goes
sorry
pan goes in wash pan pan goes out right
right with
the um plates and stuff there was like
an industrial dishwasher you had to load
the plates loaded put them in wash them
get them out get them dried wouldn't
that be easier
well i was just bad at it i don't know
how do you be bad at that i was just
at it because like dishes are more
delicate yeah yeah i can't imagine you
handling things there's that's part of
it but also it's just
there's just such volume of it you've
got to go so fast
i could do it but i was just slow right
right so therefore i could not work if
it was only me i had to be there with
someone else and i would do the pans and
they would do the um
the machine wow yeah but generally
actually quite enjoyed that job
the problem is it was always on a friday
and saturday night so you'd miss your
social life
no more cross-dressing parties for me
god
i was covered in slop this episode is
sponsored by honey we all shop online
and gentlemen we've all seen that promo
code feel taunt us
it keeps me up at night it i i can't
stand it thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes like
a peasant is a thing of the past tell me
joey what does honey do honey is the
free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best ones it finds to your cart it
supports over 30
000 stores online 30 000 30
000 and they range from sites that have
tech and gaming products to popular
fashion
brands and even food delivery i've saved
over 30 dollars on pizza and we all know
how expensive that damn thing is in
japan
but thankfully thanks to honey it's an
affordable price but god
how does it work i'll tell you how it
works connor imagine this you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
so when you're at the checkout the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds and
then honey will search for all the
coupons it can find and apply it
to that site it's that easy yes and if
honey finds a working coupon
you just watch as the price goes down
what
damn not just that god honey has found
its over 17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings b
billion with a b that's that's a big
well if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up
missing out on free savings it's
literally free and installs in just a
few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast and we would never recommend
something we don't use
so you can get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
trash taste that's joint honey dot com
slash trash taste links down in the
description below
back to the episode is killing it let's
hear it for melee
ashley bailey and ashley he's doing an
excellent job
okay i quite enjoy long flights
to the audience you just went i quite
enjoy long
how can anyone enjoy long flights well
what would you enjoy
are you in like economy when you're
running around all the time
and what are you a peasant
that did sound a bit aggressive
no because in my mind i don't enjoy like
i only fly economy and i don't enjoy
that [ __ ] yeah i feel like when you say
if someone says i enjoy flying my first
immediate thought is emirates first
class yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah
is you know being the people we are
right business
busy schedules busy lives yeah lots of
getting up running around the place
tokyo trains
hectic hectic hectic get to the airplane
no choice but to just sit there right
now nine
hours that's great and watch a damn
movie
right right so what's great about that
because it means i'm not running around
like a cycle no
i do agree that it's quite relaxing
cause it's like the one time that you
like
disconnect from the world
[Music]
actually like since they started
introducing wi-fi to planes
i actually don't like it no because the
worst part is that it's not even good
enough so it's just good enough where
you can maybe load a tweet after
refreshing like 10 years yeah
so get your hope up you paid 20 bucks
for it and it's [ __ ] no no i completely
get like the whole like disconnecting
from the internet thing because like i
remember like
one time i flew the one time i flew
business in my life
i was like oh i get wi-fi and it's fast
enough to load youtube
hell yeah all i'm going to do is watch
youtube in the end i slept for half of
it yeah
that's very comfortable yeah yeah right
people get it to sleep
right right yeah but i was like oh no
i'm gonna be in the most comfortable
position watching all the youtube i want
and there'll be no distractions
whatsoever i think i watched it for like
two hours and i was like
i'm gonna sleep i don't know what it is
about plane but for me sleeping on a
plane is like
nearby impossible like there's just like
they i can't i can't know how you sleep
with your physique
i have trouble without finding space on
like on like a plane seat as enough
as it is yeah you must scare everyone
when you walk on that plane everyone's
like [ __ ]
please i hope he's not next to me
terrorist
honestly no you're just like a giant
dude if i see someone i'm not gonna lie
i'm sitting there in economy right i see
you walking down the aisle i'm like
please
please not next to me not next to me
because i'm like i like it when it's an
old lady yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's gonna be like tiny
if there's a if there's a massive dude
on this side
next you're like well [ __ ] rip armrest
that armrest is going to him not me so
the moment i ask you to move to go to
the toilet i've made like a [ __ ]
scene
it's
next time you catch a plane you could
try reading a book
that's what i do though it gives me
plenty of time like read a book
this sounds like right like you know one
of those very pandering things like 10
things you can do on a platform
have you ever heard of one of those
before life hacks 10 things you can do
um books
contain a wealth of knowledge you can
access
during your nine hours of sitting do you
read a lot of books
i do now i never did before but it was
about
halfway through 2019. i suddenly became
a workaholic
why oh i don't know something snapped
well i was i was um
doing lots of shows in china at the time
and so i was back and forth back and
forth back and forth it's funny because
everyone on the management team is like
well it's you know it's just it's just
like a three-hour flight
it's nice and close so just it takes all
day yeah
right so you see three hour flight but
going to the airport alone it's like a
two three hour yeah
go on the airport then you know get to
the airport go through all that at the
airport then the flight then get
off the plane or stuff the airport then
get to wherever you're going it's
like a holiday for sure um
and uh so i just spent so much time on
the planes
i've watched through all the movies of
interest and you know they're going to
refresh them once every two months or
something right
you can watch a jason statham film you
know i watched plenty of those
i love statham he's a great man he's
fast and
furious but um i watched through all of
those and so
i switched to podcasts for a while some
daily podcasts and i'm just hey
time you catch a plane don't forget to
download trash taste first
so i went through that and podcasts are
kind of good because you kind of fall
asleep with them and then wake up and
you kind of
still know what's going on but i got to
a point when my ears were sore
from the things in them too much right
yeah so i discovered the magic of books
[Laughter]
did you know that before podcasts
existed people read these things called
books so there's these things right it's
called audio books but it's
just written down incredible it's
incredible
if you miss something or if you don't
understand you can go back and read just
read
it again it's amazing it's so efficient
oh yeah so what kind of books are you
reading uh what am i reading at the
moment
um like fiction non-fiction no
non-fiction non-fiction
like autobiographies and stuff like that
yeah no nothing nothing that people want
to hear about
nothing just nothing interesting i have
a a boring hobby
and i read books related to that boring
hobby i mean you have such an intense
job like
i don't really put a party to have a
somewhat you know quite boring hobby
most people who are like i feel like
have like an intense you know
showmanship right
normally have like something that kind
of looks like it brings them back down
well it's like people you know who like
spend all day every day going to like
metal concerts right yeah it's like yeah
you can't listen to metal at home you
gotta like
you know relax with some enyo or
something right it was a very successful
he was he was a quarterback in the nfl
and he was like one of the most feared
quarterbacks in the league when he was
playing right
and uh his hobby was to knit
great gigantic like 200 kilo man
knitting scarves for grandma and whatnot
sounds like a very
therapeutic yeah that's what he said he
said it calmed him down yeah yeah what
are your boring hobbies or interesting
hobbies
funnily enough like because our job
is our hobby as a hobby right i've we've
had to like i guess try to find hobbies
outside new hobbies
yeah yeah yes because every hobby that
like at least i've
pursued i've somehow monetized it uh
yeah and it's kind of like turned into a
job
the same thing everything that was once
monetized
everything was once a passion for me is
now the job right exactly what you're
saying exactly
what do you do what do you do definitely
exercise for me it's definitely but okay
kind of conor mcgregor oh carmage we're
not here to take part we're here to take
over
oh look at the iron the fighting irish
you know actually the cod is not an
irish he's not even an irish
well i was going to say because i i
guess in some aspects you
you know exercise for you probably is
part of the job right yeah
so i feel like for me because i don't
you know i don't really [ __ ] need to
do it i just do it for me it's very much
that's great what do you do what are you
doing cardio and uh lifting stuff
lifting weights like a monkey i guess
feels like you know
you like a monkey that's what it feels
like you know you never just feel like
i'm just literally just lifting things
and i come back the next day and i come
back and lift things again and sometimes
i sit there and i'm thinking like
this is so bizarre why do we do this
we just come back and i just lift things
for an hour
i feel that way on the treadmill where
you just feel like a [ __ ] hamster
like going around the wheel yeah you
feel great so it's like i need to do
this but sometimes i do have this
accidental crisis of like
what am i telling you i just imagine
like aliens coming down to earth being
like what do you humans do
we lift heavy objects and feel great
about it like okay
again you've got the treadmill thinking
that it's to generate electricity
we spend electricity you do this for fun
yeah personally i just find that you
know i'm not really trying to get like
you know in any particular shape i just
find that i sleep better i feel better
when i do it you know occasionally very
good for you
yeah just a promotion of exercise
transitions listeners you
should try exercising i feel like you
know what i mentioned everyone's like
always trying to be like a chat or some
kind of meathead it's like no it's just
chad oh my god you don't know i'm
literally a chad you are a child
hang on just a second i feel like i'm
supposed to be insulted
okay no no no no no no no you people in
the united kingdom refer to a bogan as a
chav
is that a difference no no no no no no
no it's completely different
it's a chap
don't say anything okay when you hear
the word chad what comes to mind
what image springs to mind the kid who
lived next door when i was growing up
you don't think of like the american guy
in the film who's like a kind of bully
kind of
you know like a joke no yeah he's not
everybody that's normally that's where
the meme came from yeah it's like oh
really
a lot of like american films like well
he's always a channel yeah
like the jock in the high school was
always chad or like
buddy or something so that's where the
meme came from and that means like
now it's kind of adopted into someone
who's just like now it just means like
someone who i guess is who exercises no
no no no no no it's just kind of like a
strong-willed
man i'd say this like very high
self-esteem like you know like yes
that's kind of hell yeah i'm the [ __ ]
kind of just someone someone someone who
typically
is confident is joe rogan a chad
yeah yeah i would say he's a chad i
would say
i feel like it used to just mean guy
who's ripped and massive and it kind of
like got blurred along the way to just
like yeah
guy who exudes self-confident energy
but yeah you know a lot of sometimes
people try and like mock mock them
why are you like so confused people are
appropriating names
someone
that's the japanese way of thinking
about it i would say that's the japanese
definitional version but pure and
delightful
pure and like you know untainted that's
everyone's idea of a virgin no not on
the internet
the internet doesn't know what's talking
about yeah there's this group of hive
mind of every people
who's on the internet yeah so you are
they're hobbies you get to their hobbies
yeah right yeah yeah so anyway yeah
so you are a chart um you are officially
certified chart you changed my name to
lady chad
you know what that would be perfect for
that would be like a second channel name
for a youtube channel
your main channel
top 10 ways to lift one of the joyous
things
about being a cross-dresser and a
martial artist
is probably chad's actually when i was
younger jocks and the kind of dudes who
wanted to fight
they would come and they would want to
fight the crossdresser straight away of
course
right since i'm a martial artist right
it's a beautiful thing
when a man in a skirt knocks out a chat
with a jumping spin kick that's a thing
of beauty you just get chun li on there
right yeah exactly it was good it was
good okay so like
that's the other thing i wanted to ask
as well is about like the the martial
arts because i don't think we got like
fully into how
you developed or you decided to kind of
do that as like
[Music]
thing with martial arts as well oh with
martial arts i um you know i was
i took an interest in it from a young
age you know i think like probably like
potentially you and yourselves as well
bullied a lot as a child
younger sibling i'm an older sibling i'm
the boy i'm the middle school
[Applause]
[Music]
i love how the one person you didn't
point at is the
i'm three in the lineup of four oh so
yeah i'm same yeah
we both got red beards oh
it's like the pokemon evolution
i can see the meme on reddit already you
take one of your cosplay videos
it's evolving
[Laughter]
you versus the guy told you not to worry
about
one kid who's really thin in his abs
[ __ ] that kid
that kid sucks eat pizza drinks beer all
day
still got his six pounds somehow right
right god they said god doesn't have
favorites [ __ ]
so what like martial arts did you take i
started in taekwondo
and then i went into capoeira oh wow
then i went into muay thai
and then from there the floodgates
opened i even did jeet kune do
kali freestyle grappling hubkey
where'd you find the time to do that how
how long does it take to learn a martial
arts or did you just like dabble in it
and
learn too you know i mean it's um i hear
that that's not good sorry
broadcasting that's okay it's all good
um
no you start training it's like the
thing about training is it's just the
thing that you do isn't it it's like
yeah i started training taekwondo they
had taekwondo at school and so then on
friday after school was the thing that i
did just went to taekwondo
yeah but you also listed off about like
nine different types
and you you know develops your skills
and you develop an interest
yeah and so then you get exposed to
other martial arts right right and you
say that looks interesting
looks interesting because you have a
space of comparison now
with what you're learning and what they
seem to be learning so now you can say
all right well that looks
interesting it looks like something that
could help with what i'm trying to
achieve
right right so then you kind of end up
expanding right so what would you say is
like your
favorite type i guess or like one that
you learn from the most well like
taekwondo is my first love
you know so that's kind of the one and
also because i did it when i was the
youngest it's the one that stuck in my
body the most easily
how young were you when you did
taekwondo started at 13 13 okay
yeah and this is the thing like i got
flexible before
i became a teenager and my flexibility
was naturally taken away
right so that's allowed me to stay
flexible i could still do the high kicks
on the splits
yeah oh my god i'll do them on this
table if you wanted
is there like a scale of like this
martial arts is more useful than this
one right
now because i've seen in like a bunch of
other stuff that there's just so many
martial arts that seem like they're like
almost i actually are fake or like that
they're not you know that
is that controversial to say i don't
know if that's well look this
uh debate has raged in the marketplace
community is really really good
so this is everyone has an opinion on
this and now that we've got you know
competitive mixed martial arts everyone
the consensus seems to be muay thai for
your striking brazilian jiu-jitsu for
your grappling
but then you've got to understand as
well that's sport in a cage when there
are rules
right so then in if there's no rules if
you're in war
or self-defense in the street or
something then you have systems like
krav maga which is all based around
murder basically right yeah right so
like
there are other styles like a particular
kung fu styles where you never do
anything except
strike the eyes and the throat and the
groin you know that's literally all you
do in the whole jesus
so not just there's no in my opinion
there's no best system or anything it
just depends on what you're doing with
it
right right and there are the different
you know different round pegs to fit in
around holes and square pegs for square
holes
you ever done mma uh i've trained mma i
haven't fought
i was actually interested in fighting we
were going to do it a couple of years
ago i actually started training for it
oh really
finally found a thing this man hasn't
done yet
i started training for it but it just
became apparent that it was like on a
on a cost-benefit ratio really yeah
it wasn't really good well there's a lot
that goes into it right i was gonna need
a good
two years of consistent training to
properly get my skills back
right to where they need to be for
fighting but then also you got to
consider okay so what weight am i going
to fight at
am i going to do a big weight cut let's
say i do that then afterwards
okay well now that's going to affect my
wrestling because now i'm skinny
but then also let's say i do the fight
and it goes well
then what does that really lead to more
opportunities to fight
i don't really want to be a professional
fighter you know
but now i've organized my whole life for
that sake right
so you know and yeah and like
and that's if the fight goes well if the
fight goes badly
i need plastic surgery you know i
probably might need to go back home
you know so yeah you trained for two
years to get publicly beaten up right
right right right that's tough yeah so i
thought about it actually i trained mma
and i really liked the training
i was i was interested in fighting
what's like the difference between
training mma and training just a normal
martial arts um
well mma it's everything mixed together
right right but also you have
done so many already right so yeah but
you've got quite a specific
like rule set in mma that must be
followed you know you're fighting in
either a cage or a ring right so it's
built for that environment
so in mma you do a lot of work against
walls so there's a lot of grappling
against walls because you naturally have
a wall that you're gonna meet at some
point
and you can't go further than that right
right but then you know if you were
fighting
in the desert that would not be the case
right
so it's a specific rule set so you train
for that rule set and for the skill set
required for that environment
whereas like if you're going to do like
street self-defense or something it
depends on
what attitude you want to take cause
i've always wanted to get into martial
arts but i
i didn't know which martial arts to
start with basically because it's just
training yeah sure is there like a
is there i guess like a kind of a
difficulty or is there like i assume
no there's so much difficulty well
it's more like you know like test the
button what is like that what is like
the easiest type of martial arts to get
into if you have like no prior knowledge
in it
all right because i assume there are
some martial arts where it's like you
need to have some
base level of martial arts because
they're all
systems and so when you start training
the system you start at the beginning
right right so no one's gonna put you so
there's no like type of martial art
where it's like you need to have like
prior knowledge of there's no there's no
10-hit combo that you need to know
there would be for particular like
particular forms
not the art itself particular training
environments like if you want to go to
this guy's school you need to have 10
years experience or whatever ah
okay okay but not for the art itself no
right right
straight up if you're jumping into you
know expert level when you're a beginner
then you're just making a silly decision
honestly like moving on for martial arts
stunt man
what does that involve how do you train
for that what you do on the job freaking
stunts is bonkers man being a stunt man
is a
tough gig all right so for me i was a
like actor so performer and martial
artist so those two things
just naturally evolve into yeah yeah pro
wrestling eventually right
but dude stance is hard firstly you got
to decide
you know are you just going to do stuff
like what i did was you know punching
and kicking and falling down basically
right that was fight scenes but then
stunts also includes
cars you know boats set on fire
yeah yeah like people's some stuff man
have to like flip the cars over
yeah in it which is like that's a whole
new skill set right yeah so
it really like you know it's saying what
about stunts it's kind of like saying
how long is a piece of string there's so
many different things you can do you
can't be like falling off buildings so
what was like some of the stuff that you
did so for me i was doing fight scenes
right
right um so like i trained in uh you
know the hong kong style of action
and my master i shouldn't call my master
the guy who was training me
um he was on jackie chan's stunt team
throughout the
90s and 90s so he did movies like he did
a couple of the rush hours he did
shanghai noon
oh wow he did some of the smaller hong
kong ones like the twins effect
the movies right um but like
the way they work in hong kong is like i
should stop saying like so much that's
not good enough
than us yeah they like oh my god
the attitude okay the slogan of the
the slogan of the hong kong stuntman
association he told me when he was in it
risk life save money so that's the kind
of attitude you're dealing with wow no
[ __ ]
if you just do i've never had a harder
teacher in my life
this dude was so tough right it's like
you're expected to
backflip off a balcony whilst on fire
into a pool of broken glass
and if you're like a little bit hesitant
he's like no
no you're so weak what's wrong with you
that is hard enough that is the ultimate
charge
it's just like a psychopath yeah but the
stunts attracts kind of type a
personality i think yeah yeah yeah he
was like he was telling me stories about
when
he was back in australia he was from
melbourne yeah we're in australia before
he went to hong kong was with jackie
right and just the stuff he did just as
a thing to do
was bonkers well like as a hobby hobby
but like he'd kind of do it towards
stunts
sort of but he was like one day we oh
we're driving past a train station in
melbourne
and you know there's like the bridge
that goes over the train yeah yeah
and then there's like a pole sticking up
like 10 meters away from it or something
yeah we've pulled
the dinghy donkey lights on it or
something yeah and he's like
yeah so yeah when i was younger before i
went to hong kong i was going to jump
off the bridge onto the pole
yeah i was going to do that yeah we
didn't have a camera at the time so
i'm like what i was like jump off
just for fun it's 10 meter jump from
this bridge on to catch a pole
just yeah to be like i did it just
because
here's a thing to do i think his
attitude was he would film it right
part of his stunt show reel right right
his attitude right
but that's the kind of people like just
fearless men so you're doing stupid [ __ ]
like jumping off buildings into like
glasses
yeah what did you do because i'm not
that talented
talented what talent you need i mean
like how do you train for that that's
what i wanted
there's a natural level of talent that's
required so the guys who become career
stunt men are generally speaking the
kids who were
you know the fastest runners in school
the kids who are naturally very
physically
naturally very uh i'm not i was a fat
kid at school so i've got a level of
skills just because i trained but i
don't have the natural talent for right
right right yeah
these guys man like i've got friends who
now are doing the stunts in all the uh
like the marvel films and so forth right
okay and they're just
just the moment they were born they were
better than me
after 100 years of training you know
what i'm saying mm-hmm it's like my
couple at a time
that guy can just throw himself off
building so god damn i wish that were me
back flipped out of the womb
with a six
just pack just ridiculous oh my goodness
oh my god yeah so it's like that's the
level of natural talent that's required
but also when you get that well a lot of
them just
just crazy type a personality
you have to be you can't you can't like
yeah
if you're willing to be hit by a car you
know like just stand there we're going
to drive a car into you
okay
oh good take good deck all right let's
do it again
on the ground blake's broken is that
good a lot of wrestlers as well
it's like you know okay so it's funny
we're pro wrestlers you're backstage in
the locker room yeah everyone's normally
so mellow yeah i was just like oh i want
to go
so chilled out and then okay so we'll go
into the ring and
um yeah about three minutes in or so you
can um
hit me with the baseball bat wrapped up
barbed wire
i'm like he's like they hit me with it
here last week it's still healing so you
better hit me with it here
[Laughter]
really are you sure that's what you want
me to do what do you want to do let's
take a quick break for this one minute
break
it will be right back on the voice of
africa radio network
it's funny because wrestlers will be in
the locker room and they're all
[Music]
oh and they're taping up knees and
things
like they go into the ringers
and they're superheroes yeah they go
back they're all bleeding and everything
more
blood everywhere more so
um yeah stunt people and pro wrestlers
it's what a life
what a life what a life egg credits role
i mean i mean i suppose like pro
wrestlers is just a natural evolution of
stuntman right
because because it's just like it's more
controlled stunts and you add a
narrative to it
i felt that way and also the guys who
tend to go into stunts seem to be much
more talented with the physical stuff
and i was
better at the character performance
right so for me it seemed like a much
more natural evolution all right
what are some of the craziest stunts
you've had to do
um well i wasn't that good so i didn't
get to do that
much amazing right jumping off balconies
done some of that
it's not that hard um i mean i don't
know i don't know i wouldn't want to
i wouldn't want to jump off a balcony
personally how tall are we talking here
not that tall second story
he's doing like 20 stories of things
this is how real chad does it oh my god
man it was never good enough
some people are just like cockroaches
right they just can't die
honestly like honestly it's like in pro
wrestling i hit over the head with one
of those fluorescent light tubes
right that was good that actually
doesn't hurt but it does cut you so
yeah we end up bleeding okay um that's
very awkward
have you ever gotten injured or anything
like that like properly like yeah
uh well i've probably been concussed but
didn't realize
what i'm saying okay have you not had
not
this whole thing a concussion you don't
know what's going on right you need
someone to stop you and be like you're
concussed
we need to do the whatever happens we do
what people who've done a first aid
course
because like people who play american
football like never know their customers
exactly
yeah oh jeez i think it's like they have
like the most i think they die early
because they have so much brain damage
right they're just hitting their head
constantly
but they don't know so it's the same
with mma fighters training just getting
jabbed just getting a little punches
they get
like compounded brain damage from that
not from getting knocked out it's from
just little shots over right
right um anyway so light over the head
broken glass oh sorry not wearing glass
barbed wire did some of that
like jesus yeah i did that
hit with a shovel i got hit in the hair
with a shirt with a shovel
it was a great weapon like how how hard
are we talking like
just like a little like yeah because
because like
it's a great weapon but if you hit it
with the concave side it's not that bad
on your skull
the convex side would really mess you up
oh yeah the cave side you know
folds onto your skull right right but
like to control that right in the swing
would be i feel a lot harder it looks
because like
there's an image of pro wrestling that
you know pro wrestling is fake and
everything like that but obviously the
stunts are real like
how hard do you have to go for the
stunts that you do in pro wrestling
well it depends it depends on what
happens so like
when you're like you should give it hell
really so what you're saying the shovel
right in my mind my immediate thought is
guy swing shovel tries his best to stop
it but it still hits you
is that what's happening or is he
literally going like i'm gonna hit you
hit me as hard as you can
i guess because i guess like the
audience needs to hear the sound right
yeah i hear the sound and also it's you
know
like just getting on the sound board in
the back so you want to do it when you
when you're wrestling you want to do it
you know
there's an element of come on you know
no i don't that's why
that's why i'm not a pro wrestler i'm a
version
of the chat versus the version i think
you're looking for anyone
listening doesn't sound like a version
why is it you know when a kid says that
it's like oh god this kid's going
nowhere
wow he's such a manly adult i feel like
if
if my son comes up to me at age five
daddy i love being hit in the head by a
shovel i'll be like
is it just the sheer manly energy and
the testosterone going around it's just
like just hit [ __ ] hit me i mean i
guess once you're on the stage
is the adrenaline going adrenaline and
there's something uh
somehow emotionally satisfying with it
as well so from an acting standpoint
acting is all emotion and so forth right
right um wrestling is the most emotional
work i've ever done
because there's so much emotion involved
in it's real it's real oh yeah it's real
yeah yeah
so it's highly emotional and there's
something satisfying about it
it's you know like i say it's a young
man's game it's
you want to be doing that in your 20s
yeah i think what was it like the
journal of the thing on the wwe i think
i
watched that and it was saying that
they're like they're all contractors in
wwe they're not
really yeah yeah so they're they're all
they're contractors that can't work for
anyone else
okay and then you know once they're done
they don't really get much health
benefits or anything so a lot of them
end up you know being really injured
later on
right right so yeah that's getting fixed
nowadays i hope so yeah yeah
back in the day lots of that um you know
there's something satisfying about it i
had
this was not you know really dangerous
but we found you know those
plastic wet floor signs the golden
triangle yeah yeah yeah
those are fantastic weapons oh yeah i
mean because when you hit someone with
them the two pieces of plastic clap
together so it makes a really loud noise
doesn't hurt so
it doesn't hurt so you go crack crack
crack he hit some of the head with over
and over again
so i did that in a match once it was
great okay i'm hitting the head a bunch
of times
right we did this this this spot then
later on i'm going home i'm on the train
and there's some like young girl
next to me she sits down next to me
she's like
i'm like how are you
she's like oh my gosh i think she got up
like change seats or something i was
like
and then like we got off at the station
and i walked past some reflective
surface and i'm not doing this we walked
past some reflective circus
my whole like face had turned purple the
whole
wow
people from foreign
yeah jesus christ i did a gimmick with
fire once but that wasn't that wasn't
bad from a pain perspective
you said it wasn't bad from a pain
perspective what was it bad okay what
perspective was a bad idea
insurance perspective that's the
perspective for which was bad
right you'll never wrestle in this
building again
all right i mean doing anything with
fire most 90 of the time requires
we had a stick with a cloth wrapped
around it
that'd be drenched in gasoline or
something
there's a fire truck right there the
bucket of water the piss bucket on the
side
just got on stage and take taking your
like insurance insurance
like and just say that
we had a thing one time with just
needles we used needles i
there's a shower at the facility i just
i just wash it off
in japan that's what most people like
the death the death about death match
workers in japan right that's what
they're like they'll go into the ring be
bleeding everywhere and afterwards oh to
go to the
muslim just have a shower and wash it
off
yeah so you go to the shower afterwards
there's blood everywhere all over the
shower
oh my god god damn god damn there's only
two times when there's like a [ __ ] ton
of blood in the shower
that's at a wrestling match in prison
[Laughter]
i'll leave that up to your imagination
[Music]
anyway i was not thinking that
that's not what i was gonna say i did
not expect
he's been holding on to that joke for
years yeah it's like i've never found a
place to say it
today's the day
i've hung out with you so many times on
a personal level but like
i guess like we never really go into
like as deeply as what we what you do
right so it's like i don't know
i mean i for one have never met a pro
wrestler who is also a metal singer who
is also a crossdresser who also is a
stunt man
a martial a martial artist as well
let me tell you about the time i split
the red sea let me ask you some
questions
okay um at what age did you begin
your and one may person uh
activities you're in my youtube channel
yeah uh i was
oh god it's 2013. so i was 19.
23. you were 19. yeah how do you now 26.
oh yeah yeah
i thought you were okay what did you
think i was well younger than that but
thinking about it i met you in 2016 when
you're like 21 or something yeah yeah
so i was like 22 23. to me you're
eternally 21
forever 21 forever 21 21 is not quite
forever is it
yeah i don't know like i was saying
sorry university
yeah so it was my first year of
university so that was like a hobby and
then by the time i graduated university
i was like oh i can make this a living
ass kicking
what'd you study at uni i did uh it was
this degree called
design computing which is basically like
think of a bachelor of arts
but more technology based that sounds so
i learned like uh like music production
i learned uh like 3d modeling graphic
design website design all that kind of
stuff but surely that's coming useful
in this life well yeah because i learned
video editing from one of the courses as
well so i was like oh
i like video editing that's banging yeah
i'm no longer the host of this show now
this is ladybird featuring trash taste
i'm the voice of it
let's be honest it was ladybeard
featuring trash taste from from the
beginning
let me ask another question actually
aussie
brit britt yeah got the [ __ ] ashes
right here man
explain the the choice of this american
word
trash in your name why is but not the
podcast called the rubbish rebel
unfortunately we have to cater to
americans um
with almost everything in our life
really well it's also because trash
taste is kind of a term
that we use in uh like the anime
community yeah yeah
really yeah so like if somebody has
trash taste it means like oh you know
you're into like the
the crappier shows and like the more
guilty pleasure type of shows oh you
have trash
taste in anime we haven't spoken about
anime at all we haven't have you watched
anime do you watch anime
yeah let me explain my anime bit go for
it okay so i used to be
quite an anime fan um
but i had to switch all my content over
to things that would help with my
language learning as opposed to watching
for the sake of leisure
right right so for the past three years
my prime
watching of anime has consisted of peppa
pig dubbed into mandarin
i've watched mandarin i used to watch it
every morning i didn't even know there
was a man
i'd wake up and i'd put on peppa pig in
mandarin right yeah
that's how you learn mandarin the idea
was when my brain waves were still
whatever they are when you're sleeping
or
like whatever i'd absorb the language at
that point
listen to it going to sleep and then
also waking up that was my strategy
wow and also peppa pig because it's a
children's show means the language is
nice and you know
basic easy to understand yeah yeah
normal life language as opposed to
slaying dragons and stuff that happens
yeah yeah or interesting anime right and
also the voices are recorded in the
studio so they're crisp and easy to hear
so yeah so yeah actually that's one
question i wanted to ask how did you
learn japanese
japanese well i because i'm sure many
people watching this podcast would like
to know that um
i don't recommend you learn japanese the
way i did what i recommend you do is you
go
get the school get the teachers get the
books just do it the traditional way
there's a big push in the language
learning community to not do that
anymore
right that's what has worked for
thousands of years that's
why it is the system why is there a push
to not do that because everyone's like
no you should make learning fun
no you should learning should be boring
and tedious and you should
bash your way through it with your
teacher and your exercise right because
that's how you actually
build the language properly from the
ground up what i did was i got
pimsleur's japanese
right and i would you know i went
through those programs and stuff
and then i did some lessons with a tutor
but it was pretty haphazard
i turned up in japan and just tried to
figure it out just no one around me
spoken
but now now seven years into that
journey
now my japanese are full of holes and
grammatical problems
and things that she already is now
trying to fix so it's now much harder to
go back and fix bad habits
right let's just start out probably
right that's why we do that you
grew up speaking it yes it's my first
language technically is it really yeah
damn yeah so you can't really
participate in the learning conversation
how did your vlogs learn it
i mean you're still learning yeah
oh you're really yeah because i mean
it won't be daijouba for the audience
that's okay
sorry audience yeah good boy you pulled
that backwards
well i know well i mean connor goes to
classes you don't go to
classes right yeah i mean it's it's been
hard
because you there's no way to get around
it without putting time into it
yeah and time is i feel like the hardest
fin the hardest thing to find as an
adult because
everyone i've talked to who's learned
japanese no matter what way they went
through what path they went through
there's no getting around just putting
the hours into it yes and it's like
difficult in our situation because
with our situation you know it's
different from your situation because we
can
we can go about our day and just not
speak any japanese at all and be
completely fine with it because we work
from home
um so it goes down to having to find
time outside of your schedule
to like learn japanese yeah because i'm
sure if gan
and connor were thrown into a situation
where like you're stuck in this village
in japan when not a single person can
speak english
so you just have to get you know make
your way through it by trying to speak
as much japanese possible
i'm sure anybody in that situation will
be like all right i guess i've got to
start speaking japanese right that's one
option
it's unfortunate because i mean i mean
it's obviously great that we have so
much work to do
and that you know it does it is so
successful because
you know i would love to take a year off
and just do nothing and learn it
i'd love to do that fortunately it makes
literally no sense
right now to do that because you know
everything's going so well
sure i reckon if i had control of your
schedule i could get your japanese
learning stuck in there
you've got to be um ruthless about it
you've got to find little
windows little windows of time where you
can slip it in
yeah and um the things like first thing
in the morning
yo get peppa pig dubbed into japanese
i'm not joking
i'm not joking that's great because you
can see the situations they're going
through are so
basic and every day this is my mom this
is my dad
we're kicking a ball you know yeah go
through that that's going to teach you
properly then also get your damn books
in your teachers in your class how many
pe how i just how many seasons with
peppa pig
it's not that many
how long before you started learning
japanese the point where you were like
i'm pretty pretty flowing there
being in japan it was one year before i
was
not a total maura anymore yeah two years
before i felt
somewhat competent but i'd say five
years before i really feel like i can
talk to anyone talk about anything yeah
but i don't even really still feel i can
do that you know
right right if i don't know someone they
start doing something like weird like
talking kegel
see you later man
that's like a different language
i'm like who's this jackass what you
doing talking to me like some concise oh
yeah i mean like you know kegel i guess
it's like you know
everybody everywhere in japan you know
usually you know uses it but
when it comes to different dialects like
even i'm sometimes completely lost if
i'm in the middle of the world
very confident inspiring when you talk
to natives and they're like i don't know
what they're saying and i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do like
kansai ben right is like because you
hear it so much on
tv and stuff like that it's like one
dialogue where i'm like okay yeah i can
kind of figure out what you're saying
but if i'm in like you know okinawa or
like hot say okay
or like all like hawkeye or like middle
of nowhere in hokkaido all right then
i'll be like
i think you're speaking japanese but i
couldn't tell you what the [ __ ] you're
saying did you have to so you grew up
speaking japanese
yeah but did you have were there parts
of the language you needed to study like
particles or anything yeah absolutely so
like
i did um the jlpt okay um which is like
the
japanese language proficiency test um
and
i got n1 which is the highest level i
had to study for that
uh i got that when i was like 14. i
think what a badass 14 15. but i studied
like
[ __ ] crazy good man study study yeah
that's the thing people think that like
oh fluent people or you know people who
have it as their first language
have it easy because you don't have to
study no that's complete [ __ ] you
have to study
just as hard as everybody else if you
want to get good at it yeah because the
thing is you also
you also said you speak five languages
as well which is
like one five languages yeah fluent in
english half asked it another four
what what are the four what are the
voices yeah japanese cantonese
mandarin german german i learned german
in high school
oh i can't remember it yeah but it's
been it's but i haven't spoken it for a
long time right
i went there on exchange so i got that
native exposure
right yeah but now i'm just big time out
of practice
so if i start trying to talk i would
need like if you dump me at a german
village somewhere
yeah i'd get it back you know a month or
two maybe yeah right right right i need
to go through remembering a lot of vocab
specific bits of grammar how it works
interestingly german grammar is not that
different from japanese grammar
yeah a lot of eastern european languages
actually are kind of similar to that
yeah would you say that after you
learned your first language it was like
way easier to learn other languages
because that's what i thought
see because i've heard that that's the
thing like i've heard because my my
granddad could speak seven languages
i think i think you just learn what
system works for you yeah
yeah yeah but like i've also heard that
like languages are a lot
similar to instruments where the second
one is always the hardest
and then it gets easier and easier
because you and with every new thing you
learn
you use your base knowledge from the
previous thing you've learned i see to
kind of build upon it so it's like oh
this is a completely new language but i
already know a language that has kind of
the same
base sentence structure or same
vocabulary rules
as this one i have found that to mess me
up
now i'm just confused now i'm going into
let's say if i'm going from like
japanese to mandarin yeah now i'm trying
to do
mandarin grammar but i'm instinctively
picking japanese words
right right yeah not that head ashley
good man
ashley knows what's up i imagine she
already is nodding the head i can't see
her
um so uh so but hang on but you watch
anime for like a thousand hours a day
surely no no no no no that's that's a
fact right i never ever
intended to learn japanese yeah when i
was like
you know 1780 i thought it's cringe to
want to learn
japanese from
no anime yeah that's what i thought and
then now i'm like [ __ ] i'm such an idiot
that i thought it was cringe yeah i mean
to be
fair it was like looked down upon you
was in the anime community because we
had like the whole
the whole like weeaboo movement where
people will then start like
trying to talk japanese to you online
and it's like yeah what are you doing
this is great yeah
like you know they're not really trying
to learn the language they're just
trying to learn a couple of things they
just wanted to be like that
yeah they just want to be like their
favorite anime characters and people
just because because let's be real like
the japanese you hear in anime like 99
of the time
is not the way japanese people speak
that's why you can't learn from it right
exactly
i mean i i mean i think you can learn
from it but you shouldn't
completely base all of your knowledge on
a different level it's yes you've
already got your base yeah
you talk about slaying dragons yeah i
would also say that watching anime with
subtitles
is a wholly different experience when
watching anime to learn it
because i've i've realized this now as
i'm trying to learn japanese that the
subtitles
are just distracting they actually i
think it's actually worse to learn
japanese website
subtitles on because you either pay
attention to the japanese or you read
the subtitles and it's really hard to
concentrate on doing both
and your mind your mind works
differently when it's just trying to
hear the language
as opposed to just reading the subtitles
i think actually having the japanese
sometimes
helps more yeah i would say so as well
see the sentence
i reckon i reckon you get a sentence
you watch it and you listen then you
stop and you go back and you play it
again and you read
yeah but the average anime watch is not
going to do that because they just want
to listen to the story
yeah exactly so you've got to study yeah
because because the trade-off you have
to
do if you want to learn japanese by
watching anime is just to not enjoy the
anime yeah
which is which is the unfortunate part
of it and it's what i realized
do i want to ruin this thing yeah is it
one of the last escapes i have
so i guess the only like souls to that
is just like use an anime that you
already know inside and out yeah
and then re-watch it again to be like
all right i already know the story
i'm just gonna use it as like study
material that's a good idea and you can
take like foreign movies that have been
dubbed as well that's another
strategy exactly yeah yeah um so
what anime you flogs watching well they
know what we're watching
what are you what are you watching we
never got to that what's your favorite
anime
uh uh uh
um hang on which one of those sentences
am i okay what's your favorite anime
vocano
nice that's high five that's good that's
a really that's a really good taste
why are you on a show called trash taste
but you had great taste i dubbed bikana
well i was when i lived in hong kong one
of my jobs there was i was a dubba so we
dubbed anime well you're the honk
one of the hong kong voices back yes
what the
there was a mate one of the main kids
young had some guy frieil or something
with his name uh real that sounds really
familiar
one of those kids no it wasn't scar boy
jacuzzi
young handsome not jacuzzi he was one of
the main kids
yes okay hero i'm firo i'm the old
russian man who was doing all the
reincarnation [ __ ]
really scary i have to look at your
resume
this is like an imdb somewhere does
someone
so like say you're in hong kong or
singapore or something you can watch out
of max in three languages
japanese yeah local language so like
cantonese or english
so that would be the english dubs for
asia on anime yeah so that wouldn't be
the english dub that played
on the dvd in america no yeah it's
amazing going to conventions and talking
to american dubbers
because they're like yeah one episode
would take about five weeks to dub it
we were like we did six episodes a day
get them done i have i have seen
clips from a lot of the show the english
dubs for the
market yeah yeah there are now
time to mess around so i was um
i was uh really i was
in
if for chinese listeners in uh pleasant
goat and big big wolf i was the wolf
all right you did it in chinese no we
dubbed into english
chinese chinese big time in china all
right
um we did tons of in uh we did gundam
age
i was the um flirty dude in gundam age i
can't remember his name
gundam sangokuden you must have already
been bashing these out yeah jesus christ
[ __ ] i did i just turn up you do
you do you show up what is it all right
the thing okay
all right let's knock him out jesus yeah
so you turned did you even know you
who you were playing what the characters
were or did you just turn up and there
was a script there
and you just had to read normally at the
start of the series you we'd get to do a
little bit of research
right and we get told okay here's
approximately what happens in the story
here's approximately who your character
is
and then we figure out the voice we sit
there with the director we figure out
the voice we're going to do
no no no audition process oh
audition was to get hired by the studio
right so you've been hired and now you
are good enough to do it yeah yeah um
but then we did like in azuma 11 right
yeah because there's so many characters
in that show yeah right everybody has
like a hundred characters
so you kind of you run out of voices
right the soccer teams because they
rotate through
every few episodes you just your team
from three episodes ago
starts their voices become the new teams
like you're like forced everyone's
forced to be mel brooks
basically it's just like let's just do a
hundred voices
[Music]
that was a great job but that was wiped
out the financial crisis you see oh geez
so i had a killer life before then
stop man voice actor act was dope i
can't believe you're an anime
you know they say like the jack of all
trades
yeah you know omni productions oh they
have
the funniest transformers dub you have
yes really
that's what they're doing because this
transformers dub is [ __ ]
awful but it's so so is this the same
company that dubbed dragon ball z movies
and like i think there is it might be
but yeah omni how many times it's like
yeah that was what they were talking
about this is
like twitter accounts dedicated to
posting clips from it
out of context what's happened to the
headmasters
can't they fight without chromedome so
we i just showed the boys some of the
transformers dubs yeah and um
that's hilarious all my time at the
company yeah
okay okay okay let the quality actually
go up you know
depends on what you think okay listen
when i'm doing voice acting right i know
when i'm in a project there's garbage
right
because you're a voice actor too yes yes
i know when i'm in something that i'm
like this is not good on the resume okay
you know what i mean you're right
right did you did you get that feeling
when you're doing any of these dumps or
you're like this is like
this is okay all this is like no i don't
think this is good or you just like it
should work
well you know it's like
maybe sometimes but um you got to do
what you got to do i mean i guess the
fact that we just found out that you
used to be an anime dog voice like to
say something right yeah but like
uh look there's dubbing and there's
dubbing there's kind of stuff that you
get sent to doing it some you know
commercial thing and you know yeah the
script is written in broken english
and you're just like no you just you
just record okay and you just do it and
then there's
shows like black butler which were
actual shows right right
so there's dubbing in the stomach tell
me about your um voice acting life
she started when i was uh oh my god how
old was i
15. oh my smokes like my room though
like just doing it for fun because i
loved it
like just doing like fan dubs yeah just
doing like anything and then
went to uh started doing that for a
while got better equipment
had zero training for a while and they
managed to get some
roles like very luckily um oh my god one
of the most embarrassing ones is that a
voice like
i couldn't do this now i think you go
you know you're gonna
love this so i voiced a nigerian oh
so what happened was is that again i was
like i was like 17 when i did this it
was like age of empires
like i'm sure you know that game yeah
they literally were doing a competition
where i was like
you can voice in the game i was like
fantastic and so they were big ip
right yeah so they wanted nigerian
accents and so
i i quickly open up google tap go to
youtube nigerian accent example
listen to some guy who's nigerian speak
and i was like i'm pretty sure i can get
close to this
submitted audition didn't think anything
of it a year later at the light
yeah so um yeah we use your lines in the
game and i'm like
can i re-record them like no no they're
they're in the game
the game came out yesterday it's out now
i'm like
what amazing but i didn't like sign any
contracts or anything so i don't know if
like
just did you get paid for it yeah uh
they paid me like 200 bucks i'm like
thanks
pat me on the back like get him out of
here right he's gonna say that's called
getting it done
yeah yeah right yeah yeah but like it
was like so long in between
you know when i said you know actually
can they just use your voice without you
signing it's a competition
i'm pretty sure when you send in the
competition they're you know the fine
print probably says something
so you got into league of legends as a
nigerian oh sorry uh
i'm sorry sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i mean riot games did redub
the title you can't believe me that much
it was weird because like
thank you guys i'm voicing some archer
in some dlc that like never appears and
my mate is obsessed with age of empires
right he just messaged me one day he's
like i think i found you
and he sends me an unlisted youtube clip
and it's like
you know because you know age of empires
when you're moving around the world it's
like a dark circle that comes visible
and there's a nigerian archer walks in
and he's like hello
welcome to the village it's literally
it's literally like
the ugandan knockout yeah yeah yeah and
you know i've shown clips of it before
because i just think it's so [ __ ]
embarrassing and stupid
that's not pc there's no way you could
get away with that today yeah yeah
it's as questionable it was but even in
like 2015 that was that there was like
still no problem with that right right
and that was the difference about that
being even problematic and like now i
would never dream of
auditioning for
[Music]
when i first did my um like actor
registry stuff in australia you have to
list
accents you can do right i went through
the
but then it comes over like korean yeah
just do an impersonation of my taekwondo
master tick
japanese ah just do it personally for my
friend yuji yeah yeah
languages i would never ever ever need
to freaking realize
like so i was doing that and then yeah
just came into a thing and started doing
classes got workshops got more
experience did professional work in
london for a while
it's pretty yeah london yeah so now are
you voice acting here
i have done some things here uh i
thought that we talked about the one
thing we did i can't talk about yet so
yeah yeah connor and i did something
recently but we can't talk about it the
games i don't think it's been recently
i remember you guys saw it it was ages
ago but it still hasn't been released
yeah that happens a lot yeah i shot a
thing in 2016 that came out like a few
weeks you just i mean what
i mean i feel like what you do is you
just record these things and then it's a
pleasant surprise like two three years
later
when it comes out oh yeah i did that
yeah yeah oh god i want to redo all my
lines oh
[ __ ] i sucked let's hope the world
hasn't changed around you too much in
the time yeah i hope not not breaking
anything hey guys
it's my newest uh nigerian role
i recorded that seven years ago hope you
like it
today i'm the voice of africa radio
network where an interviewing
voice section o'connor did you did you
have to do like an afrikaans accent or
did you have to like ever put on an
accent for any of the animated voices
you had to do
all the time all the time all the time
yeah because i can't really imagine like
an australian accent no the problem with
accents is that you always think you're
better at doing them than you actually
are yeah yeah because you know even if
you're very good and native will be able
to pick it apart
and they'll be like yeah because when i
did the when i did the i did a
voice for pop team epic but like the
character was um
american american it was the mayor of
new york right
in the story
it was literally the mayor of new york
and i was like and i said to the
director i was in japanese i was like so
do i have to like do it in an american
accent like i can do an american accent
but it's not
great like i'm just letting you know and
he's like no i just [ __ ] say it hey
i'm like all right sorry because i'm
dead
so i was like so i was like okay i need
to see like how far the limit is right
because usually
they don't take the first take right so
i i can just kind of test the limits to
see like
how far i can go before i have to
eventually redo it again so my first
take was dead i was like
i'm the mayor of new york and uh yeah
welcome everybody
and they [ __ ] took it they don't know
yeah because they don't know they were
like yeah that sounded really new york
when i thought i was better than i was
you know you always listed all these
accents and i
very quickly started dropping to like
less and less
even now i could definitely do an
american speaking role but i just don't
want to because i'm scared of getting
rinsed by america right exactly i'll
only do it if i'm like i'm 100 sure i
can pull this off yeah right but even
then i'm like i i
mean there's a lot of actors out there
who are so good at doing an american
accent but for some reason like
when it's the other way around like it
yeah true true yeah americans doing
british
yeah yeah but the thing is right is that
it's when you're in this really
contained environment where
you get the script before you can really
sit down and nail the action in these
words you can go
with it you can sit down with a native
speaker you can be like walk me through
exactly how to pronounce this
yeah because then people on the spot are
like doing american accent it's a
totally different thing
yeah if you coach me i can definitely
perform an american accent or
probably even like other european
accents if you gave me time to do that
one line yeah
and that's why like i think actors it
comes off like that i mean some of them
can are challenged as [ __ ] and just whip
it out and start
doing it but and but they have like
linguist coaches yeah but that's when
you have like an
accent inside of you right yeah just
like it's natural
really difficult to like actually just
on the fly switch to an accent because
you're rewriting
and it sounds like conventional coding
yeah yeah um
yeah are you a voice actor
i'm the odd one out here i've not done
any voice acting
but that was how he got my start doing
everything that i did you should have a
crack you should do what he did then you
could be voice actors
i'm not a good voice actor i mean i mean
god's voice acted in his own things
yeah i mean like the problem with me is
that there's no way for me not to sound
like me
and also i'm [ __ ] of doing accents as
well sometimes good though like some
people do want like very
much interesting voices like i i hear i
hear like my
voice acting which is like i've done
like like bare bones voice acting
because like i did like
do you know what an abridged series is i
think so yeah so it's like it's like
when you it's like
a parody dub kind of yeah of an anime
series right
and so i did i did that for fun and i
would like cast
all the main roles as like other voice
actors um and i would cast myself as
just all the filler characters that i
couldn't be
bothered to look for and i just sound
like myself in every character
it's either that or generic american
accent like 101 that like no one could
right right like i can record like any
time i used to watch
like a gigabridge like i could
immediately tell i haven't talked
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
obviously it's gone but like but that
has a but that has a charm to it i find
where it's like it's like it's like that
it's like you know watching something
and then
all of a sudden you hear your favorite
voice actor right be like oh [ __ ]
there he is i am morgan freeman yeah
exactly right
so are you i actually am
pull my skin off um what are your
favorite animes oh my god here we go
it's jesus yeah that is the question we
get asked all the time you know what
it's the hong kong
job your favorite is a little bit 14
year old so can i rephrase the question
what are you watching at the moment joey
at the moment uh i just caught up on
attack on titan
okay the whole damn thing well i mean
what it's up to currently yes yeah um
because i feel like watching attack
watching uh no i watched through series
one i haven't watched it since
yourself yeah it just gets better yeah
it just gets better because i started
series two and there was a lot of
talking and not much happening so i was
a bit like season two is like
they throw in a lot of politics into the
story and and it seems boring at first
no trust me i think i think everyone was
out there
i think everyone was at that point when
season two started they were like oh god
where's the action where's the high
octane action everyone came for season
one but then after a while you quickly
start to realize oh this is
very important to the story and it just
gets you more
invested in that world it makes the
world more and more interesting as you
go along
so by the time you get to season four
it's got the same action-packed
kind of roller coaster ride but then you
also the stakes are so much harder
the stakes are like way higher yeah um
right
so what what season are you up to now so
it's currently it's up to four it's just
like a conversation with my dad
stop watching anime and read a good
the kids book days they watch too much
anime i'm one of now i do not want for a
second want to take away from
the seriousness of the health crisis of
cover 19. but
one of the advantages of this pandemic
has there's been a lot of time at home
yeah to do things such as catch up on
anime yes so
i've been catching up on a great school
oh
it's fantastic yeah and uh ken ganashila
i haven't seen kanye's killing have you
seen barney
please everyone keeps telling me to
watch it you're a martial
here's the more important question do
you watch jojo i don't
oh you would you would you
i would absolutely you are literally a
jojo you are you are a jojo character
why have i not been put in this element
yet
you could have been in the hong kong dub
for all yeah
number x has told me to watch that oh
yeah you would absolutely love it if you
call the internet yeah you get told to
watch it yeah i potentially have no
choice yeah i mean i think i think
you'll genuinely love it and i think
with bucky as well like if you give it a
little bit of a chance i think i
but i got a feeling the reason i didn't
get into barki was like the dvd was
broken
i got a feeling it's also on netflix
that's why now this excuse doesn't work
yeah yeah um
yeah but otherwise you can't go should i
watch that because no i haven't
this is blasting me to say like i just
thought it was like infuriating
did you watch it you watched the whole
thing i was like two episodes and i was
like no it's because of the 3d
i i don't know i just was watching it i
was just like every itch
was scratched better by becky i feel
that main character whose name i can't
remember
the little weenie dude who's what from
barky no no no from kangan i should have
you know because you haven't seen him i
don't know whoever he is
i look at him and i'm like i know this
man
there are so many japanese men who are
like that you know oh really just like
me
was awesome look at these awesome men
wish i was one know and therefore i
think i have a person i hate it when i'm
on the train and someone's just choking
how awesome i am you know what i'm
saying no we don't
we're not gonna lie we don't know i feel
that something like that
has a certain uh essence of japaneseness
in it
and there are so many people in this
country who have been
forced into a profession or a series of
activities that they are not into
right and they just yearn to be a
different person right and then
they there's they'll be whatever they
are the otaku for
yeah pro wrestling or anime or idols
whatever it is
it's like they get to totally embrace
their fantasies
so to that end ken ganashita actually
despite the ridiculousness
of it feels quite real to me right okay
and i think i appreciate it now because
i've lived in japan for a long time
you're really silly hang on
right now i feel bad for calling it you
know what you should
you should my friend i'll give it
another shot do it give it a shot right
now what do i have
so you said you watched degresco have
you caught up to season three uh no not
yet see i'm getting through them you see
okay i would be very interested to see
what your opinion of season three yeah
yeah yeah what the parallels between
that king and ashley
parallels between season three and you
yeah
all right all right yeah i'll be
interested i'll be interested to see
well i'll watch the rest of our great
school you watch ken ganashila we'll
come back and do it i've got the podcast
i've always wanted to i just hadn't had
time to like sit down and watch it so
so now it was my understanding that you
watched literally every anime
no actually in that case my
understanding was incorrect
yeah so where did you get that
understanding where did you get that was
it from my name
i remember when i first met you i
remember you're being like yeah
every anime well yeah
[Laughter]
well that was also during a way to help
me out like that that was also
i'm sorry i'm sorry sorry sorry i'm
sorry no no but like
i think because when i did meet you it
was like what 2015 2016 right
back then i literally did watch
everything but that's because
that was also the time when i also
wasn't as busy as i was now okay like i
think the one reason i just can't
anymore is because i just have so much
[ __ ] going and i was wondering how you
managed to maintain
that level of sitting on a couch when
you're doing so many things
like oh by the way i watched the video
of you guys riding bicycles across japan
oh yeah
it's very clear to oh me
that's wonderful wonderful it was a
masterpiece um but i was wondering how
you managed to keep up that level of
consumption when your output was so
great
this is he doesn't i don't he does
this is interesting i think one of the
interesting things about
becoming content is the lifestyle
that is required to be content is the
opposite of the lifestyle required to
consume content
yeah 100 100 i'd agree with that and i
think
the best way the best like uh metaphor i
guess for it
is to think about professional sports um
the lifestyle of the guys on the field
is the polar opposite from the lifestyle
that people understand mm-hmm yeah
even the standards with their beer and
their hot dogs swearing and swearing and
screaming
yeah in the field getting up at 5am and
doing sprints right right but salad
i feel that's the same way when you're
doing content it's like you say what you
got into it
as a consumer you then become the
content right
and now you are to be considered that's
the problem right then and that's i
guess the dilemma
right well i mean exactly but like
that's also just the dilemma of being an
anime
content creator right it's like i need
to watch anime
to create content but because i'm too
busy creating content i don't have time
to watch
it
and i've just been trying so hard to i
guess like just try and keep up
as much as possible but without having
to go down to like
a video every two months right so it's
just like call me out
well no you're getting way better at
recently yeah you're getting way better
recently right like we're all
slow with your uploads yeah i mean like
i my upload schedule is like way longer
than either of these two
but uh i mean that's because but they
also like jam packs like a lot
more into one video i was gonna say your
videos are quite long aren't they yeah
and they're all scripted as well where
these two just turn on the camera and
just start talking talking [ __ ]
yeah literally yeah yeah i remember the
first time i helped i think joey record
one of his videos
and we recorded like a tier list oh yeah
and
uh he turned on the camera we just
started talking for an hour and a half
turns it off and he goes all right done
my work here is that i'm just like what
the video
but yeah just send it to my editor now
we're good
are the rare instances where you're like
this is just amazing because i got one
of my weekly uploads done in an hour
yeah and it required no planning but
then other times it's like i have to set
up so many [ __ ] things
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i gotta go
to x time with x
person film this blah blah blah
permission yeah absolute nightmare
sometimes
um so how did this transition happen
from doing anime content into your going
out into the world and doing interesting
japan things content
i think i don't know i don't know about
you jay but i i never wanted to be stuck
in my room doing stuff but it's like
it's the means that you have at that
time right it's like
when i was creating content i always
envisioned something bigger
that was you know more involved with me
doing stuff
and moving to japan yeah agency health
was pretty much the key to allowing me
to do that i think i think for me it was
more so
because you know i have the problem with
my name being the anime man people just
expect me to just be every video i'm in
my room talking about anime
so i always because i always had like so
many ideas to do other things that
no matter how much i thought about it i
was like there's no way i can twist
anime into this so i might as well just
not make it
but then this year especially i was like
oh [ __ ] it
like if i enjoy it and it just seems
interesting enough and i can you know
have a fun time doing it then
i'm just going to make it it's great um
that drifting video you did was
freaking cool yeah great thank you very
much i watched that drifting video i was
like um i want to go drift
i mean yeah it's really fun it's
expensive it's really expensive
very expensive like beyond beyond your
shinkansen it's expensive like the
drifting itself
yeah does it really yeah yeah i mean
alexi who uh we had on his guess he's a
professional drifter
but like yeah he said like it's one of
the most expensive hobbies out there
i mean you're basically tearing
rent cars but most of the time if you
want to drift you have to buy a car
like they do because they expect you if
because they expect that kind of just
totaled by the end of yeah yeah yeah
so you buy a car and it just sits in
that parking lot and you can use it
whenever you want and then you got to
replace the tires
yeah of course and i imagine there's
safety standards that have to be
maintained like a beast here
oh surprisingly not seat belt
regulations safety is like it's up to
you
you know yeah i don't know if that i
could be completely wrong
yeah i mean i've kind of got that vibe i
mean i got the vibe when you didn't even
need a driving license
to yeah it's private property so you can
yeah it's like driving in someone's
backyard right doesn't have a license to
drive
and jerry doesn't have a license to
strike licenses for real
i do right so they turned
we we booked this thing and i remember
there was a big concern we're like wait
these should at least you don't have
licenses what are we going to do yeah
and then
because we thought we needed like a
manual license and gun and i don't we
only have an automatic license
gun can drive manual right yeah oh okay
i just haven't done any
i don't have a manual license i'm like
well i'm going to be screwed and the guy
was like no you don't need it
just jump in you're fine yeah just learn
you're fired so i had to learn manual
like
on the spot it was horrible it was very
funny
oh god when i learnt manual it was for a
movie i shot in the philippines
right and um
i briefly lived in the philippines okay
i worked for a movie studio
right i was a producer and an actor and
so i was acting in a particular film
what haven't you done
uh i literally asked you like half an
hour ago is there any other like job
that you haven't mentioned yet
when did you go undercover in a gang
that's the drug raid i'm curious can you
tell me about it
so the way i learned manuals i had to
learn it for this movie and i'm not a
stunt driver i'd never done stunts in
cars
ever okay and they're like yeah yeah so
that's the car i would get this guy who
will teach you how to drive a manual
i've never driven manual
keep in mind it's also on the wrong side
of the road from australia right on the
other side of the car
so i there and i spend a few days
clickity-clacking buddy hopping away
learn how to do it and then in the movie
the scene that i have to shoot with me
in the car is like
dirt track in this dodgy like
countryside philippines
it's like through the middle of like a
rice paddy so it's like there's the road
and then like a drop on either side
right right
and i have to like come around this
corner
speed it up get up to like 60 or
something going directly at
the camera crew right and then they're
gonna pull back on the dolly at the last
second i have to go
and like was around him jesus christ and
i'm like you want a non-stunt driver to
do that you really want a non-stop
did you ever have to sign any health and
safety stuff or
philippines
nothing happens in japan the philippines
is going to help the safety disclaimer
brothers sorry so we're going for it but
i'm sitting there before the first take
and i'm like
well rip cameraman
but what would happen is this camera
crew as they pulled out on their dolly
one of the guys would jump out onto the
road to pull the freaking camera
didn't tell me he would do that right
right so okay your directions there you
speed up get to 60 that are the last
second just whizz around him
right so no rehearsals
[Music]
60 at this guy okay getting there
freaking out a little bit
do my zing to get around him and then a
man jumps in front of the car
jesus christ did you hit him
did he kill him i think
fine finally i didn't but
then another takeoff oh homeless man
jumped onto the road
out of the rice paddy onto the road oh
what the [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
you have lived like the experience of
like 10 different lives yeah
at least it's [ __ ] crazy oh it's
ridiculous oh my god
i just want to sit in front of a fire
with a cup of tea yeah i do
after the
but uh i guess uh to wrap things up like
where do you want our viewers to go
check yours go check out ladybeard on
the social medias
ladybeard that's one word underscore
japan ladybeard underscore japan on the
twippy twopy
and the facey bookie and the instamagram
and the old ticking talking
and don't forget to check check out
ladybird's new group babybeard
coming at you in all those same places
2021
prepare yourself world it's on like
donkey
[ __ ] i love the g-rating
self-centering
has the g-rating right there
so yeah i would like to say a huge thank
you to you
members of the rubbish rebel podcast for
having me on your establishment
today thank you for having us on your
podcast yeah this might as well have
been your podcast
when you see the comparison between your
subscribers and mine
you will quickly realize it's your
podcast
i'd like to thank you gentlemen
sincerely it's wonderful to have you
like to thank our behind the scenes crew
let's just have a round of applause for
it
they've done an excellent job and lastly
i'd like to thank
you the viewers of trash taste podcast
without your oscars
we yeah we have to do anything without
you this show isn't possible so
you got to thank the patrons you guys
like the patrons on patreon patrons yeah
we are patrons
thank the patrons i like to thank our
patrons their names
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe just shout out to twitter and
subreddit
what we have a twitter in this site
shout out to your twitter and your
subreddit
and we have spotify as well spotify yeah
don't forget to subscribe to the trash
taste podcast
on spotify there you are you gotta go
i'm ladybeard and i'll see you next time
for us like i guess i guess that's it
bye guys bye
[Music]
you